Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello.
Gumi doesn't know how to play this game.
I literally got in the call.
I was like, hey, Gumi, you know, this is like remote play, right?
And she was like, what?
By the way, at that time, we had like five minutes till the stream was about to start.
So, it was supposed to start.
So then, now we're here.
Look, guys, see, you guys were like, I can't believe you guys didn't test the stream out before... test the game out before the stream.
Gumi didn't even know until I told her, like...
I just thought it was a cute game.
It's like not my fault, man.
This was her game suggestion, too, by the way, guys.
We all know I don't.
Yesterday was a fluke when it came to testing video games because, like, dyed-haired Doki was a different person.
But today, I've reverted back to what I'm more known to do.
I saw more messages about how people were like, oh, man, you gotta test out Call of Duty because, like, because all this shit is gonna happen.
So, like, I got super paranoid.
I was like, oh, maybe I should test out Call of Duty.
But on Rival, too, I was just like, I don't know.
I was just like, well, seems like a normal co-op game.
That's what I thought!
And then I, like, downloaded the game and it says, like, only local co-op.
I mean, I could have messaged Gumi, like, a lot earlier about this because I found out last night.
But instead, like, I...
But that was my fault because I assumed you knew.
I just assumed you knew as well when you were installing the game.
Literally, it's in the Steam store tag as local co-op, Gumi.
I don't know how to read.
Can we swap games?
No, it's too late!
I got a thumbnail made and everything!
It's too late, Gumi!
You gotta figure this out!
Okay, why don't you launch and invite me?
Why don't you launch and invite me?
You volunteered.
You were like, oh, okay.
I did volunteer.
I did not volunteer.
You volunteered.
I just opened the game first.
You were like, alright, I guess I'll figure this remote play.
I thought you figured it out!
Sorry, I might have made her really loud, but I lowered the volume a little bit.
I saw that she was in the red.
I was like, oh, that's loud.
Sorry, Gumi, the thumbnail's already made.
I can't just, you know, just swap games willy-nilly like that.
I'm not on Twitch right now.
I gotta commit to the game I'm playing.
Oh, my God.
How do we commit if we can't even play it?
What do you mean other people?
Watch a YouTube video right now.
I hate watching YouTube.
You watch a YouTube video, right?
What do you mean?
I'm literally on YouTube.
That means you hate me.
You haven't even modded me.
Every time I tune in, I see I'm modded.
Look, look, look, you gotta be a special person to be a mod.
How to play Unraveled 2 Online Co-op.
Just fucking look up a YouTube tutorial anyway.
Just look up it.
It's remote play.
Just set up remote play.
I'm shift-tabbing.
I'm shift-tabbing and it won't open.
You must have turned it off.
Did you turn off shift-tab?
You can turn that off?
Yeah.
Well, no, I didn't.
Remote play to get a feature.
Okay, guys.
Okay.
Guys, we need a step-by-step guide.
Friends list.
Doki.
Remote play together.
Oh my god, you figured it out.
Oh my god, that wasn't so difficult, was it?
Bitch, you did nothing.
You did absolutely nothing.
You just sat there.
You just sat there and did nothing.
I gave you the suggestion to look up a tutorial on how to do remote play.
I gave you that suggestion.
I would say evil things to you.
You can type it out and I'll read it.
Okay, hold on.
Give me a second.
All I'm saying is that, you know, you could have easily...
Oh my god, you know what Gumi typed out?
Gumi wrote, you're the best friend, the most best friend I've ever known.
And I'm so glad that we're friends and that you wanted to collab with me.
That's crazy.
I don't think I said all that.
Oh my god, you typed all that so fast, Gumi.
You're such a speed typer.
Yeah, I played MapleStory.
Yeah, I can't believe you were able to type that entire three sentences in all this typing.
That's crazy, actually.
Hey guys, is the volume better now for Gumi?
Is she not that loud anymore?
I hate you.
Wait, what did I say?
It was just sound audio balancing.
I don't know, you just filled me with anger.
And love?
Cause that's an abusive relationship then.
Don't worry, don't worry, I'm gonna money...
I'm gonna love...
Don't worry, I'm gonna love bomb you and then you'll love me back.
Hold on.
Type in chat.
I'm waiting for you to start the game!
It says, please hold.
Gumi, input is temporarily disabled while the host is busy.
I can't even start the game!
Gumi, you have another collab to go to.
We're not leaving until we finish the game, Gumi.
I'm literally jumping around in the game!
It says, your input is temporarily disabled while the host is busy.
What does that mean?
You have the remote play thing still up.
I don't know.
It just says, please hold.
Input is temporarily disabled while the host is busy.
What are you doing, Gumi?
I'm in the game!
I'm in the game jumping around!
What are you doing?
I can't even!
I can't even do anything.
I can't even do it.
Where's your remote play?
It says you're not even playing the game on Steam.
I just sent you.
Input is temporarily disabled.
Oh my god, you cancelled.
Now I'm out of here.
Okay.
Now I'm back.
It says, you can throw the mouse cursor on and off.
You're now connected playing Unravel 2.
I said, let's go.
Please hold.
Input is temporarily disabled while the host is busy.
What are you doing?
I'm busy.
I'm just in the game.
Because I am an adult, I will google the solution.
Please hold.
What does it say?
Input is temporarily disabled.
While the host is busy.
Okay.
I don't know.
I'm reading it.
Try to install it.
Reboot PC and uninstall beta.
What?
There's no way.
Try enabling Steam Overlay.
Try enabling Steam Overlay if you can.
All you had to do was enable overlay on the host device.
Once I did this, I stopped getting me.
I tested it several times.
Wait.
What?
I'm scratching my head.
I'm confused.
What?
This is your fault.
You said you're an adult.
This is...
You have to enable Steam Overlay while in-game.
That's literally what it says.
I don't think you have it enabled.
This is it.
This is what it says.
Enable Steam Overlay.
This is your fault.
You picked the game.
Now we can't swap games because I made my thumbnail.
What do you mean?
What other co-op game?
We were here.
What?
I hate you.
It's enabled.
It's been enabled.
I haven't disabled it.
How come you can't enable it right now?
Why can't you enable it in your game right now?
Right now, I'm literally enabling it.
I'm shift-tabbing it too.
I can see it perfectly fine.
Why don't you invite me?
I'll do it.
I said this earlier!
I don't remember you saying that.
When did you say that?
This was your game suggestion.
I'm not getting into the game first!
Holy shit!
Calm down!
Oh my god!
It's just a video game.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, okay.
Let's see.
Remote play.
I've slapped my head into the back of my chair like three times already.
Are you okay?
It's over for me.
Alright.
Did you get the invite?
Yes.
Play game.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright.
Do you see the game?
Let's go!
Yes, I see the game.
Do you see the game?
Wait, did you choose the controller?
Well, it said I had to choose the controller.
Wait, no.
Wait, no you don't.
Wait.
Have you been trying to do remote play in the game?
Have you been doing remote play in the game?
When you go through the first chapter?
Is this what you did?
What?
I'm literally in the selection screen.
Like the save slot.
And you see it.
You see the save slot selection screen.
Were you doing remote play when you were in the chapter?
I told you that there was a cutscene.
Do you want me to go to the cutscene?
Go back.
Oh my god, this is...
This is why I couldn't see anything.
Because you were in the game.
You had to wait until...
You had to basically do remote play in the save slot selection.
Do your remote play.
I can't believe.
Because I need to use the controller.
Look, we figured it out.
I should have taught you.
I should have held your hand.
I don't do remote play.
This is my first time to
be chapter.
When did I say that?
Are you in the main menu?
Okay, why is it still says...
Please hold input is temporarily disabled while the host is busy.
Why is it you?
Why?
I don't know.
Why are you?
Please hold input is temporarily disabled while the host is busy.
But it works on my end.
What's wrong?
Alright, Gumi.
It's okay, Gumi.
I know that...
This is really difficult for you.
But that's why I'm here.
You sound like a mad man.
That's good.
That was my intention.
Luckily, I'm here to teach you how to do this.
So you're very lucky that I'm here for you.
I feel like I'm talking to my ex-boyfriend.
Wait, before you...
Don't select controller.
Do not select...
Please, I beg of you.
Do not select controller.
That's all I ask for you.
Like...
That's literally all I ask.
It says...
Make sure you have a controller.
No, no, no.
You don't need to.
You don't need to make sure you have a controller.
Then what?
Do I just press let's go?
No, no, no.
Give me a sec.
You just gotta be a little patient.
You just gotta...
Why are you talking about patience to me?
You just gotta be a little patient.
You know what I mean?
I'm figuring out this...
Alongside with you.
I'm gonna throw up.
Wait, wait, wait.
Cancel your remote play real quick.
I hate you.
Cancel it real quick.
Okay.
We have a little bit of an issue.
Give me a sec.
Guys, we're almost there.
We're almost figuring it out.
We're learning this with you guys.
Stop!
Stop gaslighting them!
What the fuck?
You just gaslight...
You just gaslight Chance when you're like...
Okay, Scooby's had enough.
It's your turn, chat.
No, no, no.
I would never.
I would never do that to my chat.
I would...
I would never...
Me?
Gaslight my own...
My own chat?
What do you think I am?
Okay.
Let's see.
I could be playing Deadlock right now.
You suggested this game.
You literally...
I suggested multiple games and this is the only one you said okay to.
No, no, no.
That's not true.
That is not true.
I would never do something like that, chat.
She's just...
Having a little moment right now.
Yeah, it's that time of the month, isn't it, chat?
What?
I meant she's just having a little good moment right now.
It's her day.
Okay.
Alright.
Because I am a good person.
I decided...
I don't want a controller.
Let's see.
Okay, wait.
Yeah, see?
See?
That's what I meant!
How do I...
Swap controllers...
On remote play?
Okay.
Swap controllers.
But you can...
When using...
Okay.
Wait, that I actually don't know?
Oh.
Wait.
There's no way.
How to switch remote play controls?
Oh.
Alright.
You know what?
I can do mouse and keyboard.
It's too late!
Alright, do you see the main menu?
No, I don't see anything!
You don't see the main menu anymore?
I said what did we do?
I said...
I see the main menu now.
Okay, no, I turned it off.
I just turned it off.
Why did I...
I didn't know!
The first time I put the game up...
would be the time it actually worked!
Okay, wait.
I can figure this out.
Don't worry, guys.
As the...
As the gamer here...
I can figure this out.
Alright.
We're putting this game up for...
the seventh time!
Why are you crying?
Why are you...
What's going on?
Who hurt you?
Because I know it's not me.
You did!
Me?
How did I hurt you?
You and Steam Remote Play did!
You wanted to play this game!
What do you want from me?
I want Chikawa!
I don't know what you want from me.
I want...
I'm trying to be his friend!
Oh my god!
I'm restarting Steam.
I'm fucking restarting Steam.
I'm fucking...
I'm fucking turning this car around right now.
Oh my god!
Why did I restart Steam?
Because if I restart Steam, I disappear!
Okay guys, I'm going to disappear for a sec.
I forgot.
If I restart Steam, I disappear.
Everything is fine.
I'm doing my best here.
I'm doing my best to support this family right now.
I'm doing my 9 to 5 at the moment.
This should work, right?
This should work now.
Right?
How come like...
No, now I can...
Oh, I can!
I did my Steam overlay!
I did it!
So that means...
I should be able...
to...
remote play with you.
And then...
Don't do anything!
Alright, you have...
You have keyboard now, right?
You have...
Yeah?
See?
Look at that.
Do you see this?
Okay, not chat.
Not you.
Do you see this?
Do you see it?
Yes, I see the game.
Do you see the game?
Okay, good.
I see the game.
Okay, now that you see the game...
I'm gonna put the game on my screen.
Okay.
You see the game, right?
Yes, I see the game.
Okay, are you happy?
Are you happy?
Okay.
Alright.
Here we go.
Are you ready?
Alright, we figured it out.
See, guys?
We don't need couple's counseling.
We're fine.
Everything is fixable.
Well, I don't need to be fixed.
It's like actual couple's counseling.
Okay, you're gonna make a great husband.
That's true!
She's crying tears of joy, guys.
She's crying tears of joy.
Am I the red one or are you the red one?
Like, who's the one that's dying in the ocean right now?
I hope it's you.
Oh my god!
Someone in my chat was like, Your Fuki has battered wife syndrome!
Holy fuck!
What is battered wife syndrome?
Don't look it up!
That's not you.
That's me.
I'm the blue one.
No, don't look it up, Gumi!
Don't look it up!
It's like when I didn't know what J-O-I meant.
Wait, what's J-O-I?
Don't look it up!
I learned it like last week from white men.
Oh, hey, we're connected.
I'm gonna cut the rope.
I hope you do.
This is couples therapy right now.
Wait, what are you doing?
Why are you changing your...
That's not fair!
Wait, how did you do that?
I figured some things out while we...
Wait, I can't... Oh no, I can't...
I can't use my controller?
Then what's the point?
Wait, why can't I use my controller?
No, we swap!
We swap!
You have... We swap!
What?
We swap!
We swap characters!
We can only move one at a time!
There's no way!
No!
Can you not move?
No.
What do we do?
I think it's a taking turns co-op.
We take turns.
There's no way!
No, that can't be true!
No!
That's not right!
That's how much...
The chat said that's not right!
Well, I wouldn't know because I've never played.
That's... How do we... Guys, we fucked up!
Wait, wait!
Oh no, we're... Guys, we...
We fucked up!
No, they're saying we're supposed to... Oh my god, how did we fuck up?
Okay, I thought we figured this out!
How did we... Okay, I'm looking at our report play.
How did we... How did we manage to fuck this up?
Okay.
Okay, wait, wait, I figured it out!
I figured it out!
Okay.
I figured it out.
Okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Okay, can you move?
Unbind.
Oh no.
Give me a sec.
I'm taking away your rights to move.
Chill!
Calm down!
Okay,
I need you to calm down!
No, no, no.
Do I need an Xbox controller?
I'm on my PlayStation.
I don't have an Xbox... Wait, I do have an Xbox controller.
No, no, I think it's the controller.
I think it's the controller.
Give me a sec.
I need to find...
Where did I put my Xbox controller?
Oh my gosh, it's rustling.
I can feel it.
It has to be the controller.
What else could it be?
Wait, where is the controller?
Give me a sec.
I gotta get...
I'm using a PlayStation controller.
Give me a sec.
Help me entertain the chat while I find it.
Okay, I have an idea.
Do you have an Xbox controller?
Do you have... Plug that in!
Plug that in!
I have a bootleg Xbox controller.
It's fine.
It's an Xbox.
I think that's it.
I think we just need an Xbox controller.
I don't know where I packed it.
Can we get a man in here?
Can we get a man in here to mansplain?
We can fix this!
We can fix this together!
Goobie, goobie, goobie, goobie.
Just get an Xbox controller.
I have an Xbox controller!
Get your Xbox controller and all our problems will be solved.
That's literally it.
That's literally the one thing that's holding us back.
I figured it out.
It's cause we didn't get an... We don't have an Xbox controller.
Oh wait, I have one.
I got an Xbox controller.
You don't have to...
It's fine.
No, no, no.
I got the Xbox controller.
It's fine.
I got it.
I figured it out.
I got the...
It's okay.
I figured it out.
I'm so glad people still play this game.
It's pretty underrated.
We will get this to work.
I swear to god.
We're gonna figure this out right here.
Guys, I'm gonna look up a... Give me a second.
I'm gonna look up a YouTube.
How to remote play...
How to play co-op.
Guys, you wanna watch a video with me?
You watch this with me.
We're gonna figure this out together.
It's quick and easy.
We're 39 minutes deep.
What do you mean quick and easy?
Okay.
Alright.
Remote play together.
And then...
Wait, that's it?
Wait, how do we assign controls?
How do we assign controls?
Guys, it wasn't quick and easy as I thought.
I don't want a YouTube video.
It wasn't... It wasn't as easy as I thought it was gonna be.
Guys, we're gonna figure this out.
We're a team.
I'm gonna redo remote play, okay?
I'm gonna kick you out of remote play, okay?
I'm gonna kick you out of remote play right now, okay?
And then...
No, we're gonna figure this out, guys.
We're a team.
We can do this.
Okay.
Guys.
When we figure this out, you guys are gonna, like, quickly celebrate, okay?
This is, like, our character arc right now.
By being able to do remote play for this game...
We basically unlocked a milestone in our career.
Like, nothing can stop us after that, if you think about it.
Like, if you...
Gumi, if you think about it.
Like, nothing in life can stop us.
Like, we literally unlocked...
Unlocked, like, a new way of being.
Okay.
Don't worry.
I'm just trying to press anything to play.
Why is my controller not responding to this game?
Like, why?
Guys.
Oh, there you go.
Okay.
Alright.
I figured it out.
Gumi, are you alive?
Gumi, I figured it out.
Gumi.
I figured it out.
Okay.
Alright.
Get in here.
I think I actually disassociated.
I, like, just stared at my screen.
I figured it out.
It was Xbox.
It was Xbox all along.
Oh, wait.
I'm frozen.
Gumi.
What do you know?
I just stared at my screen and...
I don't know.
I just started breathing manually.
My...
My fever just crashed.
Gumi is...
Guys.
We're figuring this out.
But...
But I figured it out.
I actually figured it out for real.
Like...
Like, it's...
It's over.
It's so over.
For...
It's okay.
You're gonna be okay.
Guys, give me a second.
I need...
We're fixing one problem at a time.
There's a lot of problems.
We gotta fix one thing at a time, guys.
One thing at a time.
Okay.
No, I did figure it out, though.
I did figure it out.
I just...
I'm just trying to figure...
I just need...
Just remember, this was your idea.
Just...
But...
Because I'm an adult here, I...
I fixed the problem.
Are you okay?
Did you say something?
I...
I figured it out!
I actually...
I literally figured it out.
I figured it out.
Okay.
But I need to figure out my other problems first.
I need...
There's other...
There's other problems here right now.
There's...
She's going...
I think Unravel 2 is, like, breaking my computer.
I'm just...
Don't worry.
You're gonna see...
Guys, guys.
It's gonna be crazy when you see I fixed this.
It's gonna...
Actually...
Oh my god.
It's gonna be crazy.
Okay.
Alright.
By the way, my preview...
My OBS preview doesn't work anymore.
So, like, I assume it's...
I assume it's working.
Alright.
You ready?
You ready, Goonie?
Are you ready to see something magical?
Are you...
Okay.
Are you ready?
Can you...
It's gonna be so magical.
Okay.
And then...
And then watch this.
Move.
Wait.
Why is my game paused?
My game froze.
Wait.
Why did my game...
Why did my game crash?
Why...
Goonie, what did you do?
My game crashed.
I'm just sitting here.
I didn't even do a thing.
Why did my game crash?
Okay.
Wait.
I figured it out.
I'm gonna close the game.
I'm gonna...
Close it?
It's 15th time.
You said I figured it out.
No.
No, Goonie.
For real.
I need a...
Okay.
I'm gonna force quit Unravel 2 real quick.
I'm gonna force quit Unravel 2.
Oh my god.
It's breaking my PC.
Wait.
Where's Unravel 2?
Where did it go?
How do I force quit it when I can't see it?
Okay.
It's fine.
Everything is...
Can you please contact your thumbnail artist?
No.
Oh, this is a bit late by the way.
No, no, no, no.
This is not too late.
You can still replay the game.
No, no, no, we are committed!
I don't want to be committed.
Oh, you don't want to be committed?
What happened?
That's not what therapy is supposed to do!
Therapy is supposed to...
Therapy is supposed to solve our marital problems.
What do you mean?
Oh, so it's not...
I told you guys, it's...
It's not a me issue in the end.
I told...
I Am willing to put in the work to fix this.
I'm actually oh my god I actually was willing to put in the effort to fix us, but no
And I was the problem
Okay Okay, all right, let's try Let's try this again, okay, okay, all right Okay, okay All right, okay, I'm gonna start a new and then start a new game slot
It's gonna be a great cutscene you're gonna love it you can skip the cutscene by the way Okay, can you also add another player add another add another play on the keyboard add another play on the oh my god I did it.
I told you I fucking oh my god.
I fucking oh my god.
I Fucking I did it.
You're fucking welcome I'm fucking
Because of this I'm gonna I'm gonna take your color
I told you I was willing to put in the effort
After 48 minutes stuck here, you're willing to just give up on us like that?
What would our therapist say?
My input is temporarily disabled!
It's a cutscene, it's a cutscene, it's a fucking cutscene!
Calm down, calm down, calm fucking down!
Give me a sec, it's cutsceneing right now, it's cutsceneing, you will be able to play soon!
You just can't watch the cutscene, I will describe, you've seen this cutscene 200 times!
I see the cutscene, I see the cutscene, it just had a fucking box in front of it!
Then just wait, the game hasn't started yet!
The game hasn't started yet, Goomy.
The game hasn't started yet.
You picked this game, you picked this game!
I was like, do we really need couples therapy?
And then you brought up this game.
You brought up this game.
Okay.
Alright, move.
Move.
Input is temporarily disabled.
Oh my god.
I don't know what you want me to do!
I've just been sat here.
I've literally just been sat here.
I don't know what to do with you.
What did I do?
I don't know.
I've done nothing.
I've just joined the Steam gameplay.
And I'm just sat here.
I was waiting for my turn.
I've done nothing.
I don't know what to do.
I don't know what to tell you.
Okay.
Can you move now?
It's enabled.
I can't move.
You're moving.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god, we did it.
Input is temporarily disabled.
Don't say that.
Stop!
What are you doing?
That's mine!
Oh my god.
Okay.
It's fine.
See, I was willing to put in the effort.
I'm still willing to put in the effort.
I put in the effort for this.
What were you doing?
You were sitting on your ass.
You're sitting on your ass again.
I work a 9 to 5 job.
And you're just sitting at home doing nothing.
You don't even clean the house.
This is a perfectly healthy marriage.
You guys are getting scared.
Oh my god.
See, this is why you're here.
You're here to problem solve.
Oh my god, push the tree.
Push the tree.
See, there we go.
See, now you know how to do things.
Wait, oh this, right?
What do we do with this?
Wait, what?
We're doing it, guys.
Look, see, we're working together.
Therapy doesn't work in the end.
We're gonna take marriage counseling.
Oh, this is just appearance.
Wait, I gotta tab out the game.
Wait here.
Okay, there we go.
Get out.
You're a strong, independent woman.
You don't need to do that.
Are you okay?
Go to the back.
Hold jump.
There we go.
I felt like I had to.
See,
parkour is not that difficult.
Why are you running away from me?
Our therapist says we need to work on this together.
This is your suggestion.
You wanted therapy.
You wanted couples counseling.
I'm the one paying for it.
Do your parkour again.
Get out.
Wait, I need to bring up my game volume.
Stay still.
I need to bring it up.
Okay, I brought it up.
Okay, here we go.
Does it work now?
Does it?
You could have been the one to host a remote play.
That's all I'm saying.
Here we go.
See, we did it.
We're doing it.
We can fix our marriage.
We can fix it.
Gumi.
Think about the happy memories we had.
How did you climb?
How did you do that?
Gumi, you can't progress without me.
How did you climb?
Okay.
I don't need your help, I guess.
What the fuck is D?
You have all the control inputs.
I don't.
Oh no.
Oh my god.
What is D on my controller?
Okay, that's okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
You have all the controls on your end.
Like, I don't.
It's all up to your controls just now.
Alright.
Okay, we can do this.
We're not stupid.
Come on, I'm pulling you.
Come on, come on, come on.
Yeah, see?
Just like always.
I do all the work.
I hate men.
Wait, what?
I'm Doki.
What the fuck?
You said that out of nowhere.
That's fucked, bro.
What did they do to you?
That was so out of nowhere.
So out of nowhere.
You just triggered a trauma response.
That's fucked, bro.
Alright.
I think...
I think you're doing something to me.
What?
What am I doing?
See, look at that.
We're gaming.
Look at that.
Guys, counseling works.
For me, I don't know about her for her, though.
Like, I feel like a better person already.
Like...
Oh, by the way, Sound Guy.
The game was brought up.
You know, maybe we should, like, you know, remember the good times we had together.
Like, bring back the spark, you know?
Like, what made it work?
What made it work?
Remember the good times we had together playing Apex?
Like, remember that?
Remember all those good times he pulled me up?
You remember that?
Oh, she's gone.
She's already gone.
Parkour, look at that.
Remember, like, how we first met?
Jump for the chicken or for the beef?
Of course I could jump for the beef.
What?
And make it, too.
Do you know there's a Parkour Civilization Minecraft server?
Yeah, I played a little bit of it.
And I was, like, debating if I should do it as a stream thing.
But, like, okay, I'll do this.
It's really I don't even think we can make it.
I don't even think I can make it through the first level.
So I decided not to.
Alright, get over here.
I'm pulling you.
Alright.
Alright, there you go.
Okay, that's on your end.
I literally have fiber.
I know it's on my end!
Wait, I need to bring you up a little bit.
Unless you want Gumi, stop, stop.
I need to bring you up.
Okay, unless you want me to Alright, here, you can move.
Oh wait, sorry, I'm going to tab out real quick.
There you go.
I warned you.
I brought up the game a little bit.
Okay, here you go.
Alright, you should be able to play now.
I remember when we first met.
How did we first meet?
I don't even remember.
You know, I remember.
I brought it up to you recently.
You did?
I'm really forgetful and you know that.
Hold on.
What date did we first meet?
What date?
Yeah, what date?
What's our anniversary?
I remember our anniversary.
Okay, go ahead and tell me.
No, because I want to know if you remember.
You don't remember then.
You don't remember our anniversary, that's so fun.
It was June 22nd.
You don't remember our anniversary.
Yeah, what year?
2019.
Are you making up dates?
Are you just making up the year?
You're making up the year.
You made up the year.
I messaged you through Twitter.
You made it.
You know what?
I said, I don't know if this is weird, but you seem funny.
I want to be friends.
And you said, oh, that's so kind of you.
Thank you for the host earlier.
I love to be friends.
That's not when we first meet.
That was not when we first met.
That's when you first messaged me.
That's not when we first met.
No, I want you to see if you remember.
You don't remember.
You literally don't even remember.
I remember, but you don't remember.
You don't even remember when we first met.
How did you get over there?
Oh, you just went down.
That's when you first messaged me.
But that's not when we first met.
All I'm saying is you don't even remember our anniversary.
Here.
Here, I pulled you up.
Just like...
All the other times.
Are you okay?
I'm just revitalizing the passion.
What are you trying to do?
Here.
What are we supposed to do with this?
Are we stupid?
You untied it.
Oh, I didn't.
Here.
What are we supposed to do?
Like...
What are we supposed to do with this?
Bridge can be tied between attach points?
We're supposed to make a bridge?
Maybe like...
You tie over here.
How did you make it that far?
Oh, you did it.
See?
You're the brains in this relationship.
Then what?
Oh, you have to fling.
What?
I have to what?
You have to fling it.
Wait.
What is he trying to make us do?
Oh!
Wait, maybe?
If I go all the way down here...
That did nothing.
This is where we have to think now.
This is where we have to think.
This is where you have to think now.
What the?
Get off me!
Why is everyone saying, Dookie, are you smart?
This is a group effort.
She's clearly not smarter than a 5th grader.
I saw you didn't know how to spell...
How many R's are in extraterrestrial?
Three.
You have to think about it.
You're thinking about it.
You don't even know off the bat.
No, it's three.
Extraterrestrial?
Spell it.
E-X-T-R-A T-E-R-R E-S-T-R-I-A Oh, nice.
You did it.
You passed.
I was just testing you.
I hate you!
Look at you.
You actually spelled it.
You don't need a head!
We don't need a head!
We can do this!
I did it.
You did nothing.
I was pressing the hands button and the thing went through.
I did it.
I fucking did it.
You're welcome.
No, it's part of the tutorial.
No, I actually did it.
I actually did it.
I did something.
You're welcome.
Is this how toxic marriage is?
Look at this thing.
This is a healthy relationship.
What are you trying to do?
Oh, a bridge.
And that's why you're not smarter than a fifth grader.
You didn't read.
I did.
I helped you.
What do you mean?
You didn't read Remote Play.
You didn't even...
I...
I figured out Remote Play for you.
I literally went out of...
You watched a YouTube video.
I did.
The YouTube video didn't even help.
What do you mean?
The YouTube video doesn't even help.
Wait, how did you make that bridge?
We did it.
Like that.
Oh my god, we're so smart.
Here, I'll pull you up.
Get up.
I had to break my string first.
You're still tied up.
You're literally tied up to that one branch.
There you go.
You gotta let go of your possessions.
Please.
Jump.
Believe in us and jump.
The yarn runs out too far apart.
Hold S to...
God, I hope it runs out.
I hope.
I hope it runs out.
I hope so too.
I hope so too, brother.
And swing under the other...
Hold the yarn and swing under the other...
Oh, I'm helping you swing.
Gotta swing higher.
There you go.
Okay, I'm here.
Alright.
What was our first collab game together?
Overwatch.
No, it was Apex.
No, it couldn't have been.
It was Apex.
Was it really?
Yeah, it was Apex.
See?
You don't even remember.
You don't...
You got the answer wrong, so we fall.
We messed through Overwatch.
The first time we played together, it was in Apex.
What are you doing?
Swing the other side!
I'm trying!
Alright.
Okay.
There we go.
That wasn't so difficult, was it?
There, swing.
No, your turn.
Okay.
You know, this just makes it so you have to spend longer time with me.
You do know that, right?
You know, like, the more you delay...
The more you delay, the more...
No, no, no!
No, don't go up!
It's slanted!
It's slanted, you fucking whore!
I
did!
I did!
I just wanted...
I just want out.
Go.
If you want out, you gotta finish this game fast.
Yeah, and the longer...
We're not ending the stream until we finish it.
You remember that, right?
Go.
Alright, fine.
Fine, fine.
We can be here.
Don't you have a collab after this?
Don't you have a fucking Mario Kart collab?
Well, guess you gotta cancel that.
Go message him right now and say you're canceling it.
Go.
It's okay, he didn't even wake up until 10pm last night.
Oh my god, fucking grip the yard!
Alright.
Because I am the adult here.
I shall.
I'll do this for us.
Oh my god, I fucking hate you sometimes.
You know what you did.
Okay, do not jump over.
Do not jump over.
Now you can.
Now you can jump over.
Okay.
Just climb.
See, we don't need to pay for therapy.
We can just play video games and solve our issues.
What was your plan?
I was going to jump.
What did you have in your little head there?
I wanted to jump.
Okay, then you do it.
No, no, no.
Okay, fine, fine, fine.
Go.
What was your plan?
Do this.
Why couldn't you do that?
Why couldn't you do that, huh?
What are you doing?
I'm waiting.
No, you do it.
You're so smart.
No, you're so smart.
You can do it.
Jump the other way.
No, I'm not going to jump.
I'm not going to do it.
I'm my own independent person.
I'm not going to let you be in control anymore.
Get out.
The house is in my name.
Go, go.
Go do your thing.
Come on, go.
You said you would do it.
No, no, no.
You clearly know more than me.
You clearly know more.
Do it.
What?
Oh, wow.
As if somebody here is actually willing to try here in this relationship.
Wow.
Is that crazy?
At least one of us is trying.
That's freaking insane.
I think you should be studied in a lab.
You're the one that's pro-lying the fucking game.
Go down, go down.
I think you should be studied in a lab.
Are you okay?
You can adjust the yard however you like.
Would me going higher help you?
Well, clearly it doesn't.
Clearly.
Just stay right there!
I don't trust you anymore.
Are you okay?
No, no, no.
It's fine.
You want to be independent?
That's fine.
I never said all that.
Alright.
Whoa.
Wouldn't it be funny if I do this first try?
Wouldn't that be funny?
That's not the try yet.
That wasn't the try yet.
How was that?
Oh, wow.
You know what?
Why don't you try it too?
Why don't you try it?
I want to know how you do it.
Why don't you try it as well?
Why don't...
Come on, get over here.
Why don't you figure out and see how that goes?
Why don't you try that?
No, no, no.
I want to know how you're going to do it.
Alright.
You got to learn how to do this too.
You want to be independent?
You got to learn how to do it.
Come on.
Go.
Oh, yeah.
Come on.
You can do it.
You'll figure this out.
I have too many tears in my eyes.
I can't see.
You'll figure it out.
Come on.
Oh, look.
You did it.
It wasn't that difficult, was it?
It wasn't so difficult, was it, Gumi?
Here we go.
We did it.
See, Gumi?
It wasn't so hard.
Now you're more independent than ever.
Come on.
Get over here.
You can't pull me out.
I'm already in the next scene, JK.
Look at that.
Guys, this is why we're so good together.
Okay.
You're also attached?
Oh, wait.
No.
We can slow time?
How do we slow time?
Are you slowing time yet?
Are you slowing time right now?
How do we slow time?
Do you slow time?
Because it's not on my screen.
I don't know.
It says press L.
I pressed L.
It says turn off slo-mo.
I don't see the slo-mo on my end.
I don't see it either.
Are we stupid?
I don't even need slo-mo.
I don't need slo-mo.
You can do this by yourself.
You know that, right?
There we go.
Wait, you guys see the slo-mo?
Oh, no.
You're saying I'm stupid.
Okay.
Wait, how do we do this?
Monkey see, monkey do.
Right, Goomy?
Why not?
Why don't you like monkeys?
What has monkeys- No, they're not.
They're just a little guy.
I hope you burn in there.
Yay.
We did it.
See?
I think we're really good together.
You should never leave.
Don't say that.
Look.
I think that was just a tutorial.
Was that just a tutorial?
Guys, did we just...
We finished chapter one.
Wait, how many chapters are there?
Wait, how many chapters are there, chat?
I'm starting to get a bit concerned.
Of what?
Of how great our love is?
There's 11 chapters.
Oh, there's Bird.
Wait, what happened to the little- That's me.
That's me.
Okay, you're definitely not the big raven.
You're not even in the picture.
That's me before I met my love.
I'm gonna shit.
What?
Wait, what do we do?
I think we're supposed to head here.
Yeah, see?
Why can't I look around?
Why am I not allowed to look around?
There's seven chapters.
Thank God.
Guys, I love my wife, but like...
You know, every time I play co-op games with you, I have fun, but then I also remember I never want to play if I'm dating someone and I'm actually like dating them.
Because I feel like I would mald.
I feel like you've trained me to mald.
But that makes it more exciting.
Whoa!
That's a child.
Ah!
Wait, what's going on?
Wait, that's us.
No, that's not.
That's a child.
We're yarn people.
That's our kid.
That's our kid?
Look, this is what happens when we argue with each other.
Look what you did.
I've done nothing.
I've literally done nothing.
Look, look.
Oh my god, now she's closing the door against us.
Look at that.
She's closing the door against you.
She hates you.
Why is that me?
You're the wife?
That's the wife right there.
That's just a man with a man bun.
That's a woman.
What do you mean?
You would have a man bun.
Of course, I'm the husband.
Look, look, look.
Oh, we were not supposed to...
Oh, sorry.
I was too busy looking at this.
Where are we supposed to...
What's that?
I don't want to push this.
Oh, you're supposed to be on this side?
I'm supposed to be on that side.
That child is strong.
That's a strong child right there.
You know what?
I'm going to tab out real quick.
I'm going to move you closer to me.
On my screen.
Give me a sec.
I'm going to move you closer.
I'm moving you closer.
Give me a sec.
Oh, I can't.
I can't because my OBS preview is dead.
I forgot.
I forgot I like...
My OBS preview died.
So I can't move you closer.
Alright.
I'm sorry.
I'm going to push this box.
Does it go faster?
No, it doesn't.
So it doesn't matter.
Oh, she jumped out the...
Whoa, where did she go?
She's trying to run away.
But you know how to do the bridge.
I don't.
How did you do that?
How did you tie the knot?
You got to teach me.
How am I supposed to teach you when you're playing controller?
I don't know.
That's...
You're supposed to be...
Ask politely.
Ask nicely.
I'll jump off right now.
You got to ask nicely.
Okay.
Hold on.
Stay here.
That's right.
There we go.
And then, here you go.
And that's how you work together.
Sometimes...
You make me like...
Genuinely manually like...
What did I do?
Get over here.
Let go.
I'm fine.
Live here.
I'm leaving.
Oh, oh, oh, yeah?
Yeah.
Oh, man.
Okay.
I feel like I'm starting to breathe through my mouth.
What do you mean by that?
I don't understand.
See?
It's that easy.
Oh.
Well, one of us was supposed to stay there.
Well, I jumped first.
No, I jumped first on my screen.
I was first.
But because I'm the adult here...
Go, go, go.
Go.
See?
Oh.
Look at that.
This is how you can be a mature adult.
And compromise.
Yeah?
This is not gaslighting, chat.
I'm just...
I'm just trying to say therapy works.
Okay, here.
You know what?
Why did you send me to my dad?
What are you talking about?
I would never do such a thing.
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
I knew you would.
What happened to trust?
You're so stupid.
You're so...
I literally have prep time.
Oh, yeah?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
You want to keep doing that?
Cancel your Mario Kart collab right now.
You want to keep doing...
Yeah, look how you cancel four times on me.
You're such a bitch.
Alright.
Nice.
See, that's not so difficult.
Wait, we should...
There's a secret here.
How do we get over there?
We don't need a secret, fuck it.
Alright.
Yeah, fuck it.
We're not here to complete the game.
We're not here to be completionists.
We just want to make sure we pass therapy.
Move the box.
Oh!
We ran away with another kid.
Oh my god.
Who's he?
Who's this child?
I don't know, but there's men.
And I don't like them.
Yes, you do.
What?
Alright.
What's that?
That's fire.
Don't touch the fire.
You know what happens when you touch the fire?
Whoa.
That's what happens when you touch the fire.
What?
Oh, you're so good at this?
Okay.
It's just easier.
Oh my god, we're so cold.
What the heck?
He's not gonna kill us.
What if I die to it?
You don't even think about me.
You just left without thinking about me.
I thought you were an adult.
I am, but I just wanted to see if you love me.
The answer varies on a day-to-day basis.
Come on.
Yeah?
What?
We don't need to...
We can do this as one person.
Okay.
You made it last time, we can do it again.
You're the one that's supposed to move.
No, you can move.
No, I can't.
Okay, let me fix that.
Okay, let me fix that too.
Let me fix that.
Oh wow, that's too bad.
Where are you going?
Come on.
Don't you want to finish this game?
What are you doing?
Somebody here is stalling.
Here we go.
See?
We're so good together.
Here, I'll hold.
Oh, you're gonna hold?
I don't trust you.
Go.
Okay, fine.
Yeah, this is why I don't trust you.
Get closer to the- Oh my god.
What are you doing?
What are you- Oh my god.
What are you- What are you doing?
What are you doing?
Jump.
Pull the string.
I see you not pulling the string.
I see you not...
Pull the string.
See, guys?
Now you know who's the actual problem.
What are you supposed to do here?
You stay right here.
Okay.
And then I do this.
Oh, okay.
And then what?
Can I push this back over?
Oh, okay.
Then what?
Okay, stop pushing it.
Oh!
God, I'm so smart.
I hate men.
Wait, I'm jokey.
I think you're supposed to get all the way up there.
Yeah, I think so too.
God, I'm so smart.
Alright.
What do we do here?
That's a trick question.
I know what to do here.
I like how you were actually thinking it was a puzzle.
I hate men and joking.
Let's go, men.
Let's go.
Oh, it's so cute.
Why aren't they killing us?
I feel like they...
I got squirted on.
Gumi?
That's what you did.
I was just showing what you did.
Can we...
Oh no, there's the kids.
Cat!
Wait, I think that's us!
One's wearing a yellow shirt, one's wearing a purple shirt.
I'm the little boy!
I don't think they customized it like that, I'll be honest.
I think they did.
Why are they wearing our colors?
I think that's us.
Okay, now you've tangled up the yarn.
I hope you're happy.
You've tangled up the yarn.
Go back and untangle the yarn.
Go back and...
Oh my god, okay.
We're fine.
We'll have it your way.
Because I am willing to compromise.
Okay, fine, fine, fine.
I'm willing to compromise again.
That's fine, that's fine.
I'm willing to compromise for us.
I'm willing to make sacrifices.
What sacrifice have you made?
My brain.
My brain cells talking to you.
Every day, every day I talk to you.
I sacrifice a little piece of me.
But you still come back.
It's an abusive relationship.
This is love.
Through and through.
Skateboard.
Okay, you gotta push it.
You wanna kiss?
No, get away from me.
We gotta reunite the spark.
Sometimes the spark is just gone.
We ran out of fuel.
What do you mean?
What do you mean we're enjoying this?
That's us.
We did it together as we should.
Wait, why are you doing that?
Do we?
I don't know.
I am.
Why would we need to bring that bucket?
Oh, maybe we do.
Wait, yeah, yeah, it's a ramp.
Wait, have you played this game before?
Did you not make it?
We come out.
Let me break it.
There's one here.
I still don't know how to tie knots.
It's okay.
One day you'll learn how many T's are in extraterrestrial.
Four.
I already knew that, I just wanted you to spell it out.
Did I not do it correctly?
Is it not tied?
I think I need...
No, because you can't tie it.
Yeah, because somebody didn't teach me how to tie a knot.
How do I do it?
How did you tie a knot?
Is this how you tie knots?
What button do I press?
Oh, I figured it out!
And then...
How did you do it?
I have a knot tied over there.
Yeah, and then you have to press it again here.
Untied it.
Oh, wait!
Push it!
Wait, wait, wait.
What?
Will it let you push the bucket here?
Maybe.
No.
Oh.
Then why does it let us connect here?
Because you're on it?
I don't know.
I tied a knot.
I did my job.
Oh, we can tie one there?
Yeah, right here.
No, no, no.
I meant on the corner.
Oh, you did it!
See, that was so hard.
Alright, your turn.
Wait, wait, wait.
Because I think we have to tie it up there, right?
Oh, yeah.
So maybe I have to do...
Wait, but how do we get to that side?
Oh, maybe we have to push the bucket down here.
Because we got used as a step.
And then we gotta do this.
And then...
Swing around.
Like a little merry-go-round.
Yippee!
We did it!
Do we not need the bucket anymore?
We do!
Why else would we make a bridge?
See, because we need to get up here.
See?
We did it!
Why did you help me?
I did!
Last time I helped, you wanted me not to help.
So I just let you do your thing.
Okay.
And then...
We climb up.
Okay, and then we climb up.
And then you swing.
You swing.
You...
That's it!
Oh my god, you're so smart, Goomy.
I don't want to hear it after I figured out the first couple of puzzles.
You're so smart.
Wowee!
You swing.
I know I swing!
You gotta chill out.
You gotta relax a little.
I'm just helping out.
I'm just trying to help out.
And then we do this.
And then do like a...
Come on.
There's seven chapters, Goomy.
We gotta speedrun this.
We're supposed to be gamers.
Alright.
Spin.
Go.
I'm very supportive of my wife.
I'm glad I had a filling breakfast before this.
Alright.
We gotta swing.
Woo!
Okay.
Nice.
I knew you could do it.
We're so good together.
Yeah, she's saying that out of love, guys.
She doesn't actually hate me.
That's just her acting.
That's just her acting, guys.
She's just...
I thought we said we're not gonna be completionists.
What's going on?
Okay.
What are you trying to do?
What?
No, what the fuck?
What the fuck?
Yeah, but why the fuck did you go with death?
Because then how are we...
How are the kids little dull people?
Because we're like a figment of their imagination.
I don't fucking know.
Oh, I wanna go for death?
Oh, thank you.
Oh, you're not gonna help me pull this?
You're not gonna help me pull this?
You're gonna make me do everything?
Oh, I knew it.
I knew it.
Alright.
What do we do here?
We gotta pull the other thing.
Your turn.
Alright, let's go.
Let go.
Yeah, she's just a tsundere, guys.
She's just...
She's just acting.
We gotta spin together.
We gotta spin together, Gumi!
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm tired.
You're fucking welcome.
Castle your Mario Kart collab right now.
It's fine.
Kenji doesn't even...
Actually, he set a couple alarms.
Maybe he will be on time.
Oh my god.
Clearly...
Because I'm trying to pull you to this side.
You fucking idiot.
We could have swung together.
Yeah, you could do that without my help.
Let's go back.
No, we're not.
We're not going back.
I already know what you're like.
It's too late.
You can't change it.
You can't change the past.
Get out.
You can't change what you did.
You gotta live with your mistakes.
You gotta live with it.
Get over here.
We can do it.
I refuse to do it.
Get over here.
You think you can just fix your mistakes like that and I'll forgive you?
What mistake?
I'm the one that made the jump.
And who pulled you up there?
I said we didn't need to be pulled.
I said I didn't need to be pulled.
What do we do here?
Do the jump.
Make the jump.
I'm holding on to you.
Why do I have to do the work?
My job is to look pretty.
What are you going to say to that?
What are you going to say?
What do you have to say about that?
Nothing.
I can't say anything.
I don't know what you want from me.
That's what I'm going to say.
Make the jump.
Here we go.
You see, you see guys.
You know when to not.
There are moments when you know you should not say anything.
There are moments in life where you know when to not say anything.
What the fuck?
How do two kids do this?
Are they teenagers?
They must be.
They might be children or tweens.
They could be tweens.
They look like tweens.
I haven't heard the term tweens in so long.
Hey guys.
You like watching?
Weeeee.
Okay, I have an idea.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
Oh.
Look at us.
Look at us go.
The fuck are tweens?
It's like in between teenager and child.
Adolescence.
Yeah.
Wait, what's the age for teenagers?
I don't even remember.
I don't even remember what the cutoff is between tweens and teenagers.
Wait, how do we do this?
You didn't tie it.
I did tie it.
Yeah, I did.
I just untied it.
Yeah, why did you untie it?
Just get up here.
Oh.
But don't you have to...
Don't we need the wrench?
What wrench?
Oh.
It's like between...
Like 10 and 11, no?
I don't know.
It's just 10 and 11?
I guess so.
It's like 6th grade.
I believe.
Yeah, tweens are 6th graders.
Oh, I don't need to spin this or anything?
I think it's just...
Oh, I think it's slanted so you fall down.
That's why.
I assume that's how physics work.
Or that crow fucking comes up there and just fucking eats you.
I hope it does.
Me too.
Oh.
Get up here.
That's why I was thinking about it.
What's this?
Do you have to tie this?
Yeah, because then it makes us jump up.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
And then we do that.
Or fling it.
Get over here.
I need you to let go.
Trust me.
Let go.
It's not gonna be like Titanic.
Never let go.
Never let go, Jack.
Alright, here we go.
I've never seen Titanic ever in my life.
I've never seen the full movie.
I've always seen like...
Wait, how do we do this?
And then you connect it and then you tie a rope.
I did it.
Oh my god, we worked together!
Okay.
That's why we can't have nice things.
This is exactly why.
We finally worked together and then you didn't even commit to it.
I committed.
You didn't even commit.
You let go.
What the hell is happening?
It's climbing on the walls and shit.
Parkour.
Oh, you couldn't do that?
That's alright, you'll learn.
I'm watching the pattern of it, you fucking bitch.
I'm analyzing it.
Oh, there's more.
Wait, what?
Oh, here.
Oh, it's gonna touch you.
It's gonna touch you.
I wish you could push in this game.
Get off me.
What?
I thought this was a loving...
I thought this was a loving relationship.
Oh, it's like Mario!
You got this, I believe in you.
Go, Goomy, go.
I think you were supposed to...
Goomy, why aren't you here?
Goomy, come on.
We're waiting for you.
Come on, Goomy.
Alright,
I'm ready.
Why didn't you spot me?
Why didn't you spot for me?
This is technically the gym.
This is...
I'm working out right now.
Holy shit.
That's insane.
Wait, what does this do?
Oh.
You're supposed to hold...
You let go, you let go.
Alright, I'll hold on.
I'll hold on.
I didn't even notice.
You see, you would've been ready.
But you weren't ready for me.
I don't think I'll ever be ready.
What are you doing?
Why did it take you 20 years to tie a knot?
I tied it.
It's just I'm thinking about how to get over to the other side.
Oh.
Wait, you're right.
No, you have to go on the other side.
Yeah, and then you tie that.
And then, yeah.
Okay, that's fine.
You can do that again.
It doesn't blow me when I'm midair?
No, you have to be in the hole.
The hole's the goal.
Okay.
I'm going into the hole.
No, you're not supposed to go in the hole.
You need to tie that thing and then you go in the hole.
You gotta be patient.
I need to get close to it.
Just let go.
What are you doing?
Okay, now you drop down so you can go to...
You can tie the knot on that thing.
And then you jump in the hole.
What are you so scared of?
The hole.
The hole's not that scary, Gumi.
There we go.
See?
We did it.
Alright, nice.
It's gonna be...
Maybe we...
No, we can finish this game.
I believe in us.
Untie it.
I think we can finish this game.
It's not that bad.
Wait, what?
Oh!
We're supposed to turn it.
You're supposed to turn it.
What are you doing?
How do I go up there and turn it?
I don't know.
We're just slamming our heads.
You're the one that's been jumping the cannon!
No, I don't know what you're talking about.
There's not a yarn thing to attach it.
Is there?
Maybe like...
Wait, there has to be.
Right?
Oh!
See, I told you we gotta turn it.
Okay, and then...
I do this.
And you jump there.
And then you...
Use it to swing.
Use the momentum.
No, no, sorry.
I meant you climb up.
I mean, you could do that too.
No, I meant like...
I meant like you...
Okay.
That's fine.
We all make mistakes here.
You want me to climb up and then jump up, right?
Then why would you say swing?
And then you push that.
And then...
See?
It's that easy.
Look at that.
We work so well together.
You're like a little cockroach scuttling around.
I'm scuttling!
I'm doing it!
I'm actually scuttling right now.
I feel like playing with you...
Makes me feel like I'm playing League of Legends in my brain.
Wait, why?
What does that even mean?
Oh my god, it's showing me a video game.
See, guys?
Therapy works.
That's the portal.
Where is it going?
We did it!
We finished Gap Chapter 2!
Five more chapters to go, Gumi!
Five more chapters of absolute bliss.
Guys, in five chapters, our marriage will be saved.
Alright.
That's how easy couples counseling is.
It's just that easy.
I think we can speedrun these.
These puzzles are actually so easy.
Not gonna lie.
I'm like 100% sure we can speedrun this.
I think that's an elevator, right?
Okay.
Do I let go?
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna push this and you're gonna push the...
Turn the knob.
The other side.
That's why it's okay.
I think I want to kill you.
I'm giving you encouragement!
I want to kill you.
I'm literally encouraging you.
What more do you want from me?
You'll never be satisfied if even that doesn't save the marriage.
Time me out.
You don't need to look at the game anyway.
Let's go, let's speedrun!
We can watch the cutscene while we're speedrunning!
Come on, let's go, let's go, let's go.
I'm already...
What do you want from me?
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
I think we fucked up the speedrun already.
We're supposed to push the flowers.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh.
We're speedrunning.
Wait, then what do we do here?
No.
I'm trying to push the flowers.
Flowers this?
No.
What?
What flowers?
Guys, I think we're failing the speedrun.
Wait, go?
I don't know.
What do you mean?
I don't...
You wanted to push the flowers off the desk.
Do it.
Why don't you try swinging?
Let go.
Go ahead.
No, no, why don't you try swinging?
Clearly, you're better at it than me.
No, no, no.
I'm giving you a strong...
You don't even know how to take compliments!
This is why it's not working!
You have issues to work on as well!
It's not just a me problem!
You made me like this!
Go, go do your swing.
You're really good at this.
There, see?
Alright,
here you go.
Your turn.
Do your swing.
Do the swing.
Oh,
shit.
Wait, what?
Wait, how did I miss that?
Speedrun.
Why didn't you swing?
Don't kill me!
That wasn't on me.
That actually wasn't on me.
Why did you attach yourself to me?
There you go.
Okay, go.
Yay!
We're doing it.
We're so good.
You need to push the car.
You need to push the truck.
I just want to stand still!
Fine, fine, fine!
Fine, I'm fine!
I'm willing to compromise.
I will do the brute work here.
Fine, is this what you wanted?
This is what you wanted.
You want me to push?
Princess, this is what you wanted, princess.
Okay, princess, you go.
You go.
Don't worry, princess.
You stay on that bullet.
Don't hurt your little legs.
Don't strain too much.
What the fuck?
Wait, what the fuck?
Is that guy kidnapping the children?
Who the fuck is that?
Stranger danger!
That's a frog.
Frogs aren't strangers.
Dammit!
Woah, woah, woah!
I'm inside of you!
Just run!
Why?
Run.
Just run.
Literally, stop pushing things.
Stop pushing things.
Just run.
Just jump and run.
Why are you pushing the can?
Why are you...
Just run.
You don't have to push anything.
Literally, that's all you have to do.
Just run.
It's right here.
That's right.
So, how was that?
How was that?
We didn't need it.
That was just... We're not here to be a completionist.
We're here to finish the story.
That's our goal.
That has always been our goal.
Did we actually finish the story if we didn't 100% the game?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, what's going on?
Wait, what the fuck?
There's multiple...
Wait, what?
Oh, we have to do the thing again.
Okay, I'll push this.
Hello, little princess.
You ready to go over there?
There we go.
How do I get over there?
Oh.
Wait, I figured it out now.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
How do I get over there?
I mean, I think you need help.
I think.
Wait, I think I figured it out.
Wait, wait.
No, no, no.
I figured it out.
Wait, what?
Get out.
Get out of there.
Okay, we need to figure this out.
Unless...
Oh yeah, we start from the right and then...
Wait, how do we do this?
Why are you looking at hints?
We don't need a hint!
We are smarter than... Did you sniffle?
I'm sorry I raised your voice at you, but sometimes, like, you know, we don't need help.
Okay, we...
Why?
Why did you pull me?
Anything over here?
There's nothing over there.
There's nothing over here.
There's nothing...
Why am I scary?
We're trying to figure out this problem together.
Can you jump off?
Okay.
So get up here.
Jump off.
Jump up and then off.
And then push the barrel.
And then you go over here.
And then you hold on to it.
And then we did it.
See?
Look at that.
I told you, we did not need help.
We don't need to ask for directions.
We didn't need to ask for directions, Goomy.
See?
I knew you were smart enough to figure it out yourself.
I just wanted you to use your potential.
Oh, this is a beautiful day, isn't it?
Yeah.
Do you need to color the flowers?
The what flowers?
Do you need to color the flowers based off our characters?
Oh, I think so.
Yeah, it's yellow and purple.
Or pink.
Oh, that's cute.
That's really... I like that little detail they did there.
Ah, demon!
It's following me now.
It's following me, so I need you to...
I need you to...
Wait, we need to do that thing again.
Yep.
Yep, we did.
Yep, just like that.
There we go.
Here you go.
I'll pull you up.
Don't worry, my little princess.
All right.
Don't worry, I'll swing for us, too.
It's moose.
Meese.
Moose?
Yeah, that's the plural form.
It's meese.
Okay, you just watched me die.
Okay, that's cool.
I don't know.
Don't watch me die?
Okay, I'll close my eyes.
Wait, you never heard the plural form of moose before?
You've never?
I'm a California girl, Doki.
Yeah, it's like goose and geese, so it's like moose and meese.
Meese just doesn't sound mean.
So does geese, too.
Just run.
Don't look back.
Just keep running.
Just hold my hand.
There you go.
Look at that.
That's all that.
That's all you have to do.
Oh, oh, there.
It's time.
It's...
Wait, how do we... How do I get this out?
Oh, and push this.
Go down.
Nice.
And then you do that.
And then I'm gonna go down.
And then... Oh, now it's following me, so I might die.
That's okay.
Like, it was a good life.
All right, pull me fast.
Pull me fast.
All right, let's go.
Let's go.
See, that wasn't so bad.
Go, go, go, go, go.
All right, I'm gonna push this.
I'm gonna push it.
Go do your thing.
Go do your... Okay.
Okay.
Oh, please, please, please, please, please.
All right.
Okay, stay there.
Stay there.
Stay there, so I can...
Oh, oh, god.
Oh, god.
Okay, I'm okay.
I'm okay.
Just stay there.
Just stay...
Leave.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
All right.
No, it's not.
Look, it's up.
It's up.
It's up here.
That's not a secret.
I promise.
Oh, the green stuff is safe.
The green stuff helps you, like they can't touch the green.
They don't wanna touch grass, so we're fine.
It's fine, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine, I'm safe.
I'm safe, I'm so safe.
I'm so safe.
I am so safe.
I am not safe.
I'm not safe.
Just remember what you did.
Just remember.
What are you trying to say?
You didn't say that before.
I did.
I did say that.
Oh my god.
It's fine.
We're so safe.
Like, what is he gonna do?
Eat us?
See?
Look at that.
Nothing to worry about.
If there was a zombie apocalypse...
I would have saved your life if there was a zombie apocalypse.
That's all I'm saying.
Wait, what?
Oh, we're supposed to push the can.
Go.
Sacrifice yourself for our love.
Push the can.
The other one.
Here we go.
All right.
Now what do I do?
What the fuck do I do?
Wait, wait, wait.
You jump on... you see that tree bark?
You see that tree bark down there?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You have to push the grass.
You have to push it so I can...
Are you pushing it?
Go to the can now.
It's looking at me.
Oh!
Look at that.
And that's how you save a marriage.
We're doing it.
Okay, this music is actually pretty nice though.
I'm in.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
We didn't... look, see?
We don't even need to work together.
See, I'm sorry.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm alive.
Oh my god, I'm gonna die!
FUUCK OOOH hahahahah Get over here...
OOOOH I'M GONNA BE DEAD I'M GONNA DIE
AHHHHH hahahah We've been clutch by one I fucking saved us Okay, I got Eden You take your time No, no, no This is a speedrun, Gumi This is a speedrun, let's go Pretend it's Minecraft parkour Right here How do we do this?
Okay Pretend it's Minecraft parkour You know, like when...
Oh, we're fine See, we're saving Look at the seconds we're saving Look at all the seconds we're saving from doing that How is there so many of them?
You're supposed to be on the other side You're like peeking your eyes You're supposed to peek your eyes up here And then, you know You know, I'm gonna do that And then you can, you know, come over here Cause he's looking at me now Like, that's good And then...
We swing And then...
We're so smart See, we're so good for each other Look at that, our brains working together To solve basic problems Like, look at us go
What's he gonna do?
Oh my god Like how he's...
You're the closest
Come on, Gumi No, don't touch the shiny thing No, Gumi, don't touch the shiny thing You don't know where it's been Get over here, you don't know what touched it
You don't know where it's been
We don't want you to keep hoarding You have a hoarder problem, we're trying to stop that
Oh, we got another one I found it back, and now we filled a painting Okay, the secrets are for the paintings No, they're not
Okay, why do we need the paintings for anyway?
Like, what's the point?
It's not even a...
Oh Well, if you think it's pretty, then like...
Then I'll let you think it's pretty Look, we're at chapter 4 Look at this, look at us go Oh, what time is it?
Oh, we have plenty of time Oh, wait, it's lore Guys, it's alright, what's the lore?
I'm picking up more stuff This is why we have a hoarder's den You just keep picking up random stuff you find on the street And what of it?
We don't have space anymore What do you mean?
Oh, that's me Trying to...
Like, what is this storyline?
I don't know Why did this kid just stay home?
Were they gonna be sold or something to Harry Styles?
What?
I don't...
Look, there's the shiny thing Don't you want your shiny thing right here?
Here you go Alright, climb over it That's right And now I'll pull it for you Okay, okay, you know what?
I think I know how to do this You jump over and then you jump over several times You do this And then you do this Cause it's like a little yo-yo I don't want my string to be tangled And then Okay, do you want your shiny thing?
Do you want your shiny thing?
Alright, okay Okay, and then And then you pull it Pull it
Are you pulling it?
There you go I don't think you had to loop yourself that many times No, I did I definitely did Okay Okay I can't You gotta I can't get down
Alright Okay Okay There we go There's your shiny thing Are you happy?
Why did you get down?
Are you happy?
Are you happy though?
Why did you get down?
Now it's your turn
It's twisted
How do I get up?
Okay, pull Can you pull real fast for me?
Thank you Okay Okay Gotta thank you
I gotta thank you
Don't look at the hint Don't look at the hint Do not look at the hint I know you wanna look at the hint but don't look at it Don't look at it Don't look at it
That's all I ask of you I don't ask for much.
Don't look at the head!
I know you're looking at the head!
I know you're...
I think we're supposed to start from the left side.
I think.
Why are you still?
I don't understand why are you sniffling.
Okay, I can't... I need you to let go.
Like...
Okay.
Oh my god.
Please.
I'm trying my best here for us.
I am trying my best for us right now.
My hands are off my keyboard.
Here, I'll even start clapping.
Yay!
Go, Goki!
All right.
Yeah?
I know what to do.
I think...
Get up here.
No, you get up here.
You get up here.
You know what I think it is?
Watch this.
Stay here.
Gumi, what do you want to say?
Gumi?
Gumi, do you want to say anything?
Why don't you say something?
Do you want to say anything?
No.
Do you want to say anything, Gumi?
Do you want to say anything when you lived multiple times over that stupid yo-yo?
I saved us with that.
I...
I don't think you did.
I problem solved that for us, Gumi.
Somebody had to think of something and...
You told me not to say anything.
I thought, you know, all I'm saying is that somebody had to think of something and I didn't see any ideas coming from this other person in my game.
And just like that, you can solve a lot of puzzles.
Let me untie that.
This is a team game, Gumi.
Go on.
This is a team game.
Like... Oh, look at that.
Look, guess who solved it?
Wow.
Okay, go on.
Guess who solved this?
No, guess who's very mature about all of this?
You know?
Go on.
Push the fucking brick.
Push the brick.
I thought you could do it all.
No, you don't need to push the brick.
Just go on the bridge.
Go on the bridge.
Alright.
There you go.
That wasn't so difficult, was it?
And then we go underneath here.
Mhm.
Go on the other side.
Other side of the plank.
No, no, no.
Jump on...
Jump on the other side of that plank.
Right there.
Jump.
Huh.
You need the brick.
If you wanted a hint, that is.
Alright, do it.
Do it.
No, no, no, no!
No, no, no, Mrs. Smartass.
You do it.
Mrs. Smartass, you do it.
No, no, no.
You are so fucking smart.
No, do it.
I need the fucking brick!
You clearly know what it is.
You fucking do it.
Oh!
You are going to sniffle.
You're gonna sniffle.
After you make me- making me do all the work, you're gonna sniffle right now.
You're gonna- you're gonna- Yeah?
Yeah?
Oh, why didn't you push that brake when I told you to?
Huh?
Why- oh, somebody didn't push that brake when I said, can you please push that brake?
Oh.
My character's pointing?
Yeah, yeah, I'm seeing- I'm seeing it.
I'm seeing it.
Somebody decided not to, you know, push that- push that for me.
Well, I feel like earlier, I heard someone say, we don't need the brake, just jump on it.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
At first, I was like- No, and then I was like, can you please push that, but then you didn't push it.
So I was just like, you know, fuck it.
We don't need it.
You know, we don't need it.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, here we go.
If I could fucking push this brake into you right now- I'm just gonna leave.
I'm just gonna- I'm gonna quit this collab right now.
We're never gonna solve our marriage, and we'll never finish this game.
Is that what you want?
Is this what you want?
Is this-
I'll turn this car around.
I'll fucking turn this car- I'll turn this car around.
I'll actually- I'll turn this car around.
I'll- I need you to also do- I need you to fucking- Ty, we need two strings.
We need two strings.
Give me a sec.
It's not fully tied!
Okay, fine.
Fine.
You're so smart.
I'm fine.
Fine.
You were not clapping.
You were not- no, you were not.
You were- you were not clapping.
You were actually not clapping.
You fucking bitch.
You were not clapping.
You were not.
You were actually not clapping.
Do it.
Come on.
What's going on?
Do it!
Oh, what happened?
What's going on?
Huh?
I don't know, why didn't you do it the first time?
Because I...
I decided to let you do it because you're so good at it, you know?
Yeah, I am good at it.
Oh, now you accept compliments.
Wow.
That's actually...
First time for everything.
Oh, hey.
Are you okay there?
What if you tie it?
What do
you mean?
What are you trying to do?
I'm gonna tie it.
Why?
Please, I'm...
Please start swinging.
I...
Hey, why'd you let go?
I don't know.
Why did you...
Why did you stop loving me?
I'm so good at it.
What are you supposed to do?
Dude, I tied it.
Maybe you're supposed to tie the other end.
Okay, here we go.
Are you supposed to tie that one?
Can you even sleep?
Well, if you want to sleep, you have to come over here.
What?
I can't.
I can't move because it's like at the very end.
Are you out of yarn?
Yeah.
Here.
What the...
I have to untie.
Okay, come over.
Okay.
Oops.
The fuck?
Why did it...
All right.
Why do I have to come over?
No, we can't.
We have to...
Oh, we can.
Oh.
Why did we tie it?
Oh, okay.
And so, we wasted like five...
We wasted five minutes just...
Just for that.
Yeah, isn't life beautiful?
We could have seen the longest bridge in Unravel 2.
Swing.
All right.
That's fine.
My little yarn arms are tired.
I sense something dangerous approaching us.
No, there's nothing dangerous here.
Gotta be a man.
What's up?
What happened to you?
Who hurt you?
Who...
It's like...
I'll let you take a guess.
I know I'm not a man, like...
Like, who hurt you?
Are you okay?
I wanna play Dead Log.
You suggested this.
You suggested this game.
You cannot say that.
I think it was like...
I put this here.
Oh, okay.
Look, we did it.
We're a team.
Get over here.
Okay.
Look, look.
We were so behind that the little fucking spark was like...
Are you guys good?
Like...
Even the spark was like...
Hey, look.
We're wasting time here.
Okay.
Nice.
Like here, isn't it?
Wait, what's this for then?
What's this for?
You okay?
You okay there?
Look, it's just...
Look, just climb up.
Just climb up.
Gumi, just...
Oh.
No, don't go down.
Don't go down.
I was supposed to swing from that.
All right.
Go.
Swing.
There you go.
Oh, you did it!
Oh my God, I'm so...
No, no, no, no, no!
I'm trying to climb up!
No, no, no!
Don't do anything stupid here!
No, you love the parkour!
You literally watch parkour...
She watched the entire parkour civilization video, by the way.
When the only...
When the only like fun parts was literally the beef and chicken part.
Like, then the rest was just whatever.
Like...
She literally watched the entire two of them.
Wait, what's this?
Gotta pull this up.
Oh!
Okay.
And then we gotta push this here.
Oh, I gotta bring you up a little bit.
Gumi?
Gumi, what are you doing?
Gumi, why did you do that?
I didn't like our ropes being tangled.
That's...
That's the whole point.
I don't like it.
Gumi, that was...
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna push you up a little bit on the square.
That was...
That was the entire point, Gumi.
Like, why did you...
Why did you do that?
Why?
You know what?
I'm just...
You get... Everybody gets one.
Everybody gets one.
Some people get more than one.
And like, that's just love.
If somebody still is trying...
What?
No, you have to...
You push the other...
You...
Push it.
Okay.
All right, let's do that again.
All right.
Okay.
You see where I'm going with this?
You push it up.
Yes.
Good.
No, no, keep going.
Keep going.
Oh.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Push it.
Don't push it up.
Don't push it.
Oh.
Okay.
All right.
Okay, let's do this again.
I'm very patient with you.
For the kids.
Keep pushing.
Yeah.
Yeah, are you doing it?
Yeah, you're doing it.
Good.
There, there.
Y'all, you see what I did there?
You see what I did there?
You see what we could have done in the first time?
Did we have to untangle our rope?
No, no, no.
What are you talking?
You see what we did the first time?
No, you see...
Let's untangle our rope.
Go down.
Go under.
All right, now you know what to do, right?
Now you...
Okay, I'll push it.
No, no, no, no.
All right, all right.
No, no, not yet.
Not yet, not yet.
Go back.
There you go.
There we go.
Now push it.
Yeah.
Yeah, there we go.
There we go.
And then...
You did not need to...
Okay.
You didn't need to tangle it.
Yeah, that's what I said earlier, but you said no.
That's what you wanted.
No, no.
No, that's not it.
Yeah.
No, no, Kumi.
Kumi, Kumi.
No, that's not...
Earlier, you said...
No.
Exactly like this.
No, no, no, Kumi.
I did not, Kumi.
I was like, oh, no, I want to untangle it.
Kumi.
And you're like, okay, you don't have to.
No, no, Kumi, Kumi, Kumi, Kumi.
We figured out the solution.
You don't need to do this, Kumi.
I just want to show you that I wanted to untangle it and you yelled at me earlier.
No, because you were doing it wrong, Kumi.
That's not because I yelled at you because you were...
Because you had the right solution.
I yelled at you because you were doing it wrong.
Come on, we're a team here.
At home?
One day?
Yeah.
No, that's insane.
No, no, no.
Clearly, you have a lot on your mind.
No, I mustn't.
All right, go.
Do the swing!
Oh, my God.
Oh, you missed.
Oh, you missed again.
There you go.
See?
Eventually, you get there.
This is a good time to tap out.
No, don't hug me.
No, no.
No, we're past that point.
You stupid bitch!
I just remembered something.
You never come back to me.
But what?
What?
I'm confused.
Wait, what time is it?
I forgot.
Guys, finish this game first!
We need to finish this game first!
Get off!
It says input is temporary in the game mode!
Oh, my God.
Get over here.
Get it.
Yo, this way.
It's down here.
It's down.
All right, here we go.
Now, we go downstairs.
Wait, there's a tie here.
Yeah?
Are you- Are you okay?
Are you- Why'd you do that?
Are you okay?
We have to do that again because we fucked it up.
We have to do that again now.
Now, we got it.
Okay.
All right, let's do that again.
We were supposed to do- We were supposed to be over there.
Yeah, yeah.
You're supposed to save my life, you know?
Like, we're supposed to- Yeah, yeah.
Oh, thanks.
I'm literally holding down the button.
All right, how about I hold it, you know?
How about...
Yeah?
There we go.
Clearly, clearly somebody's here.
Clearly, someone didn't jump.
No, clearly somebody here knows how to save another person's life.
Clearly, someone didn't jump up and save themselves when I was holding down the button the entire time.
Someone just didn't have their own hands and wanted me to do all the work, but it's okay.
Like, sometimes it's okay.
Like, I don't mind doing all the work sometimes.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You don't mind?
Okay.
Yeah.
No, no, no, no, no.
You said you don't mind.
I said that all the time.
When would that be?
I always said sometimes.
You get one every hour.
Oh, but it's been two hours, so I should get another one.
No, no, no, no.
I think I'm done.
I gave a lot of freebies to you.
It's like charity work, if you can tell.
Yeah.
Maybe, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, don't worry.
I'll hold S and up like I did earlier for you.
Oh, wow, you're so sweet.
Wow, my god, you're so sweet.
How does this game exist?
I've played more than a game that had actual divorces.
No, no, no.
You're fine.
You're fine, Gumi.
If you don't really want to work together, that's fine.
No, that's fine, that's fine.
I'll hold S and up again.
Okay, yeah, yeah, sure, yeah.
Oh, wow.
Thanks for holding it.
Hey, what happened?
I was holding S and up.
I don't know.
I don't know what happened there.
Oh, you want to learn how to do this again when you watch me do it?
Yeah, you want...
Oh, you hold it?
Oh, yeah.
Hey.
Yeah, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Go, no, go.
Do your swing.
You're so good at it.
Do your swing, sweetie.
Do the roar, Shrek.
Do the roar.
Do what roar?
Come on.
Do the roar.
Do what?
Do it.
Do the roar.
No, you have to give me an example.
I don't know what you're talking about.
No, no, no.
You have to do the roar.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Well, I guess we'll never know.
God.
Are you scared of water?
No.
Then why didn't you jump?
Why did you wait until I jumped?
I'm scared of frogs.
What's wrong with frogs?
Oh, look, that's me.
I don't like looking at frogs.
Why not?
I feel like I don't like animals that aren't mammals.
Well, to be fair, they're like extra slimy and stuff too, so...
Oh, wait.
Hey, don't die from that.
Wait, then what's the point?
No, before I went to like an Asian market with my grandma.
Oh, that's the point.
There's fishes here.
And she ordered a frog and then they skinned the frog alive in front of me.
Wait, no, don't say that.
Don't say that.
That's just trauma.
No, don't say that.
Don't say that.
That's actually so gross.
I've actually dissected a frog.
I've dissected an iguana.
What?
In college.
Yeah, in college, they...
Because I was going to study to be a vet...
I'm okay.
A vet tech?
Yeah.
And while studying...
I sacrificed myself for you.
Okay, well, I can't do that twice.
Why did you jump at the right time?
Wait, how do we...
I think we have to wait.
Yeah, why didn't...
We don't jump on the fish, do we?
I think we do.
I'm pretty sure we gotta jump on the fish to use it as like a...
As like a boost.
Down the lily pad and with the...
I got...
We gotta bait it.
Yeah, I think we gotta jump on that lily pad and then another one.
All right.
Okay, and then we do it.
How do we bait this?
Oh, there it is!
There it is!
There it is, see?
Yeah, we bait it.
I know like iguanas are invasive species.
So they're like...
It's fine.
Because like the whole purpose is to get rid of the iguana population.
You know how they like...
It's actually crazy because like when I die...
Because they like freeze the...
Did they freeze the iguana?
Hey, look there's a shiny.
Did you not want that?
How do we get it?
I guess we'll never know.
Well, too bad.
Do I have to tie it too?
What if I have to tie it as well?
Oh, here.
There you go.
Oh, okay.
So do you want me to get it for you?
Do you want me to get the shiny thing for you?
Yeah, I can actually get the shiny thing.
Do you want me to?
Say please.
Say...
Please!
Alright.
Please who?
Please, Doki!
Alright.
Get over here.
Oh, it's back.
I know he's not.
He's not back.
Oh, he's back.
He's back.
He's actually back.
Okay.
Whoa!
Look at us go.
Yippee!
Okay, see we're fine.
Oh, we killed it.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god, we should eat it.
Oh, where was God?
No, we didn't.
He's still alive.
I didn't get passed out for a bit.
Yeah, I think he was just tired.
See, everything is fine.
Oh, we dove into the water.
Yeah, I told you.
Everything's okay.
How are they going to get home and who were those men?
We'll never know.
Good.
To find out, we actually need to finish the game.
There you go.
Come on.
Get over here.
Get over it.
Let go.
You gotta let go.
You got...
This is a trespaw.
You gotta let go.
You gotta let go!
I mean, you can tie that.
Are you not gonna tie it?
No, I think we're supposed to pull it, no?
Are we supposed to pull it?
Maybe.
Are we?
Because what are we tying it to?
I can't pull it.
Maybe...
Wait, no.
Pull...
Pull my side.
My side.
Here.
You pull it.
I think we need two.
We need two.
Wait, no.
What?
Okay, wait a minute.
Is there anything up here?
Because it lets us jump up.
Oh.
Oh, hey.
Yeah, see?
We are supposed to tie it.
And you tie the other thing.
Okay.
And then we...
Wee!
I feel like we do, yeah.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh.
Wait, what?
You pull it.
And my toe's stuck on the thingy.
No, no, no, no, no.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then get on it.
Get on what?
Oh!
Oh, yeah!
Wee!
And then you swing through.
Gotta swing in through here.
Look at that.
Teamwork.
See?
Our marriage is fixable.
Brick.
Oh.
Wait, you have to tie this or...?
We need brick.
Is there another place to tie up?
This.
No, because I think that's supposed to break the floor.
No, here.
There you go.
And then...
Wait, what's over here?
I feel like SpongeBob.
Oh, wait, what?
What's this?
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, stay in there.
Wait.
I'm trying.
lol I'm trying.
There you go.
All right.
And then...
What if I go up and you stay right there and then you tie it?
I can't tie anything here.
Can I?
Oh, I can.
I can.
Yeah, yeah, here.
I tied it.
There we go.
Wait, no, no, no, no.
Oh.
From where I tied this.
I think I can tie here.
Okay.
Oh, and you bring the brick over.
You gotta bring the brick over.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then we tie the second bridge up there.
Yeah.
But you have to tie it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I'm gonna put the bridge in here...
Uh, the brick in here.
Yeah.
And then I'm gonna attach here.
Oh wait, I accidentally untied it.
You're gonna have to tie your side again.
Don't worry.
I do my job.
And then I bring it over.
And then...
We did it!
Wait.
No, we didn't.
We didn't do it.
Wait, wait, wait!
You push it and then...
You push it, you push it, you push it.
Push what?
Push the brick, push the brick!
I do the jump!
Whee!
Oh my God, I almost fell off.
See, look at that physics.
Why is it so peaceful now?
I know, right?
It makes me feel calm.
Yeah.
Uh-oh.
What's that?
No, what is that?
No, it's just the music's changing.
It makes me feel like something's about to happen.
Oh, there's a swan!
It's a sleeping swan!
Oh my God!
Oh my God, she's sleeping!
It's like a little freaking...
Oh.
Oh, there's us.
What's happening?
Are we adults now?
Oh my God.
What do you mean we're adults now?
I think they're the same size as you are.
Whoa, girl.
Shiny.
Shiny replay!
That moment where I realize she's actually a girl.
My bro's a girl.
Holy fuck.
Female.
Mind blown.
Oh, shit.
We have to go all the way up there?
How the fuck?
Oh.
Oh, they unlocked it!
Why the fuck can't just like just do everything on its own then?
Yeah, why didn't he does for?
You can literally unlock shit.
I can open portals and shit.
Okay.
Right side.
No!
Right!
Sorry, I was pressing alt to jump because I've been playing MapleStory.
Okay.
Is this one?
We're making good progress.
All right.
Oh, now it's evil.
It's scary.
Yeah, why is it scary?
Stop picking up shiny things off the floor.
You don't know where it's been.
It's going to be worth millions in the future.
You don't know.
What is it?
What do you pick up?
Oh my god.
Fuck.
Oh, oh.
Whoa!
Oh, shit!
Don't let them!
The po-po's here!
Don't let them get you!
Please!
I didn't pay my parking tickets.
Let's go!
I don't even drive!
I didn't pay my parking tickets!
I can't get caught again!
Scatter!
Another evolving Skye's Pokemon trainer box.
What?
It's worth $700 now.
You can sell it for $700.
What the fuck?
All right, Jesus.
It's the fuzz.
Get up.
Get up here.
Get- Get up.
All right, speed run.
Speed run.
We got this.
Let's go.
We can't let the cops get here, too.
Why is the string so fucking long?
Gumi!
Why is it so long if we're supposed to go?
I'm looking around...
So we can do the things we need to do.
Here we go.
All right.
You want me to raise you up, princess?
Oh, go, go.
I push it.
Wait, I don't push it?
You don't know that.
Wait.
Oh, oh, here, here, here.
Up.
Get up.
All right.
I want to feel tall.
Yay.
Careful.
Look, it's right here.
There's a monster right here.
You can't jump here, so you gotta be careful.
All right, so here you go.
Do what I do.
Oh, wow.
Wowee.
I literally said careful like three times and you just ignored it.
I think we need to jump from this and then...
I'm scared!
Gumi, it's easy.
It's very easy.
You just...
You hold...
Okay, you see?
I'll tell you when to jump.
I'll tell you when to do it.
Now.
See?
Look at that.
You said it as I was already jumping.
Oh, there's a guy up there.
I didn't see.
Okay.
Oh, there's that.
That's also a death hole.
But like, it's so hard to see this one.
It's actually...
This one's actually like difficult to see.
Oh, it's like Mega Man.
We gotta do this.
Nice.
See?
Look at that.
Speedrun, speedrun, speedrun.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
Oh, wait.
What are they doing?
They're going through...
Oh, they're still hiding.
They're still hiding from the adults.
Oh, no!
That's me!
No, don't you do anything!
You just let me get kidnapped like that!
That was me!
God save me!
It's really nice in this game, isn't it?
We gotta save...
Oh my god, we gotta save me!
Let go.
You slide down, you slide down, you slide down.
There's a little hole there.
You would know if you save me.
Huh?
What'd you say?
Jump.
There you go.
Oh my god, we gotta save myself.
Wait, don't you agree that the soundtrack is pretty nice in this game?
No, it is.
It's actually really nice.
It actually controls the mood right now.
It calms me down from my anger problems.
Huh?
I gotta swing.
Do you think I can make the jump?
No.
You see how I did that?
I hit the wall?
Now you do it too.
You gotta learn.
You have to learn.
You can't rely on me all the time.
There you go.
You can't...
Okay.
I've been pressing...
I've been pressing down instead of left to guide the rope back.
Oh, yeah.
I don't know why I've been pressing down.
Oh, this is timed.
Right?
Yeah.
It is.
I don't know why I've been pressing down.
This is like Mega Man.
Come on.
Get over here.
Whoa, there's rats!
Oh, I have to step on this and then...
And then you go up from here.
And then...
Uh...
Oh, okay.
Then what about me?
What about me?
Is there nothing to help you up here?
Oh, well, then I pull it.
Yeah, you pull it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, I need you to let go.
And then I'll pull you up.
But then, don't we...
No, you have to press this and then I go up here and then I can pull you up.
No, no, no, no.
Yep, here we go.
Here we go.
Teamworks.
Get over here.
Come on.
There you go.
My leg fell asleep.
Oh.
Oh, you sit crisscross?
It's not good for your legs.
But that's you.
Oh, now you're gonna try and save my life.
Does that need this?
I don't think so.
I don't know.
I mean, we should just see what's ahead of us first.
Yeah, we don't.
See?
I understand that we're two very different type of players.
But you want to go ahead and see.
Like, just run ahead first.
And I'm very much the type that, like, wants to sit around and look at things.
And that's why we're in counseling.
What?
Oh, we have to jump up.
Yeah.
We're gonna jump to the left.
I think we'll find out when we're up top.
I can't jump because you're here.
Please.
The yarn isn't long enough.
Yeah, see?
It's up here.
Okay, don't get...
Okay, we gotta wait here.
And then weeeeee.
Weeeeee.
And then we...
Oh my god!
Gumi.
Please, Gumi.
Please!
This is what we learned, Gumi!
This is literally what we learned together!
This is what we learned!
We learned this together!
Please!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I think the shiny's still left.
Do you want it?
Oh my god.
Oh, what happened?
What happened to the shiny, huh?
What happened to the shiny?
Didn't you want the shiny?
You're right.
We should get it.
No, it's too late.
I already...
I lied.
There's no shiny.
I just didn't think you would actually want it.
Okay.
All right, okay.
Come on, Gumi.
We're gamers.
Come on.
Come on, let go.
All right.
See?
Everything is fine.
There's no shiny.
It was a myth.
It was a lie.
It was a lie to bait you.
You are just like a man.
What?
Gumi, who hurt you?
Everybody lies.
Doesn't matter.
I'm lying to you right now.
What?
Gumi, women lie all the time.
It's not...
Anything...
I'm doing it right now.
All right, here we go.
Why don't we do this one?
We swing...
We can't swing past it.
Is that green thing something?
Maybe?
Can you try walking up it while I'm hanging onto it?
No, it's a conveyor belt.
It's a conveyor belt.
Oh, it is?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't think the green thing's anything because we can't interact with it.
Yeah, I don't think so either.
Do we just swing really...
Oh, we just keep swinging maybe?
Oh, we swing.
We swing to the very top thing and then...
And then bounce over it, I think.
Oh, wait, how the...
Oh, no.
Wait, I think I can...
I think I can use you.
What?
There we go.
Wait, wait, no, no, no, no, no, no.
All right, Dodger, you're just making this harder for yourself.
You're just making it harder for yourself.
You say you're gonna use me.
Because that's the mechanic of the video game!
Gumi, maybe you need...
Why can't you say use your help?
I don't think it's a couple's counseling.
I think it's individual therapy right now.
All right, get over here.
Get over here.
All right.
Oh.
No, we have to...
That's for the shiny.
No, no.
It is?
Is that for the shiny?
Oh, okay, then we don't need to do this.
No, no, we have to do this.
Yeah.
Yeah, we do.
How do we do this?
Oh, wait, wait, I got it, I got it.
We tangle it up.
And then, yeah, yeah, okay.
Okay, I figured it out.
Hold on to it.
Wait, what?
There you go.
Get up here.
No, no, Gumi, no, no, no.
You're not getting the shiny, Gumi.
You're not getting the shiny.
You're not.
Dang it.
Alright.
Wait, I can.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
You're not getting the shiny.
No, no.
No.
No, no, no.
You're not getting the shiny.
No.
I just...
Alright, you get one try.
You get one try.
You get one try and I'm pulling you over after that.
Are you happy?
Get up.
I am.
I remember what I did for you.
Well, I suddenly really wanted...
Doenjang Jjigae when you said that.
I don't know why, but like...
I suddenly had a craving.
But I ate that like two days in a row, so maybe there's something going on.
Alright, let's go.
I'm...
It's fine, it's fine.
Just...
Do that.
Is that what I did?
You see that shiny over there?
Where?
Oh, I didn't see the grain on the floor.
That's how I feel after that.
You said, you see that shiny over there?
I think I have to
go at the bottom, I think.
Because I pressed the button for it.
Yeah.
But if you want the shiny, it's this way.
I can figure it out.
Get over here.
Wait, how do I get over here?
I see it.
How do I get over here?
You can't.
It doesn't go back up!
I thought it would go back.
You only get one shiny.
Oh.
Push it down.
And then I do that.
And then...
Wait, how do we do this?
I could crush you right now.
You swing?
Swing?
Yeah.
It's hard to get momentum on this, no?
Okay, wait.
Wait, I wonder how high it goes.
No, you crush me.
Yeah, it gets crushed.
Can you press it?
Press it and then maybe...
How do we do this?
Can you jump on it?
Oh god.
Wait, wait, wait!
I got an idea!
Press the button!
And then...
I swing here.
Okay.
No, I pull you up!
Wait.
Here.
Let go.
Oh.
Well then, I guess we'll leave.
Well, we figured out how to do it.
Okay, okay, okay.
You go over, you go over.
Okay, and then...
You press it, you press it.
You press it and then I go over.
You let go.
And then...
Oh my god, wait.
How do we do this?
Wait.
I think we have to tangle this.
Or let's...
You swing here, you swing here, you swing here!
Oh, wait.
No.
Wait.
Okay.
My leg.
I feel like you have to do this, though.
Like, you just swing.
But then, how are we going to untangle the rope?
That's a good question.
Maybe...
Oh, wait, wait, wait!
Maybe, like, if you go on the other side and then...
No, no, no, no, no, and then...
Can you come down?
Go, go, go left, go left, go left, go left!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, go left, go left, go left.
Go left, go left.
That's what I was thinking, yeah.
And then...
Let go.
Press the button.
Oh, no, because you can just get up there and climb up.
Yeah, oh yeah, here, yeah.
You climb up.
Alright.
And then, my turn.
Look at that!
Therapy works, guys!
Therapy works!
I'm gonna get therapy once in my entire life.
Go to counseling!
Whoa.
Wait, it's...
Oh, wait, what?
I think it's a timer thing.
Is it?
Does it look...
Then what?
Oh, it's a swinging thing!
Swing?
Then...
Oh.
Okay, you go, you go.
I hold.
Okay, now come over here.
No, no, no, I think it's like...
Yeah, yeah, you drop down, you drop down.
You have to drop down.
Okay.
Okay, but the thing is you have to stand closer to the right.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, like here.
And then I have to like, slowly go up and down.
What's up?
Okay, okay, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Holy...
You guys, it's not swinging!
I know, it isn't swinging!
It's the momentum!
You have to go slow!
Slow and steady, slow and steady.
Yeah!
There's so much power in these hands.
Do you see that shiny?
No.
You get one.
Stop talking!
I didn't move!
I didn't even move.
I didn't move.
I saw you.
You got one.
You get one.
I told you, you got one.
You got your one.
I told you.
You moved and then you blamed me.
I didn't!
I didn't move!
I didn't move at all.
I did not move at all.
I literally stood still.
My hands are sweaty.
That was on you.
All right.
Here you go.
Is that slow enough for you?
Go down, go down, go down, go down.
Go down!
But the shiny is right there.
Go- I said you had one.
I said you had one.
I said- I gave you a shiny or you- I- you had one.
You had one chance.
It's not my fault.
You fucked up that one chance.
It wasn't my fault!
It's not- It was not my fault.
You fucked it up.
I did not move.
There we go.
Oh, the shiny.
Be careful, don't fall down the roller.
What happened?
What happened over there?
Oh hey, be careful, don't fall.
This was a little faster than- Wait, what?
It hit my head.
It like bonked me in the head and I got concussion.
Okay.
Nice.
You're so sca- Oh, we can't.
We have to...
Be a little...
We have to do it really fast here.
Okay.
Here we go.
You saw that?
Wow, we're getting better.
We're so- We're gaming.
We're actually gaming.
Look at- Oh shit.
We're- Look at me go.
Look- Oh my god, you ruined it.
You ruined the one thing that gives me joy.
You ruined the one thing.
You ruined the one thing that gave me joy, Gumi.
Like, I was parkouring like fucking crazy right there.
That's the meaning of life.
I can't-
Oh, what's over here?
Do you think there's a shiny?
No, I think this is the way to go.
No, that's literally the way to go.
All right, how do we do this?
Oh, we have to do this fast.
Well, Gumi, remember- Remember when I said we have to do this fast?
Remember when I said we have to do this fast?
Yeah?
Well, I'm going to be patient and wait for the next one.
Oh.
And look at that, you're doing it fast now!
I'm so proud of you.
Wheeee!
This could be a fun ride.
But like, not like, with like less casualties.
I think we were- Oh.
I saved your life.
Hahahaha!
Okay, I can't save that.
I can't- I can't save stupid.
Gumi, we're almost done!
This is chapter five!
Gumi, please.
Wha- What ha- Wait, wha- Where did you go?
Where did you go?
I don't know, I couldn't see myself anymore.
Oh my god.
You didn't commit!
You could have committed!
You're committing issues.
No, I don't!
Hahahaha!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, that's what they all say.
Wait, okay.
Oh, I was like- I didn't realize I was- Where are we?
Is this a fact- What factory are we in?
Yeah, what does that say?
Where's- What?
No, get over here.
No, this is- Get over, get over, get over, get over, get over, get over, get over, get here.
We're not here to read.
We're here to die.
We're not here- AHH!
Man, that's what I thought.
You did this.
You did that on purpose.
I bet you wanted me to die like that.
Wait, how do we- Oh.
Okay.
Do you memorize how this was gonna go?
We're doing it.
There's electricity below us, so don't get electrocuted.
Huh?
Why were you so silent when I said I bet you wanted that to happen?
Why were you so silent after that, huh?
Why were you silent when you said that?
When I said that, huh?
This is why black widows exist.
Oh, dang it.
Oh, oh.
Again?
Please.
Please, we were able to do this before.
How did you- How did you forget?
No!
No, my god.
Okay.
Okay, we have to do it instantly.
We have to do it instantly.
Okay, like right now.
Like right now.
Okay, there we go.
What?
Oh my god, are you fucking serious?
What are you doing?
Okay,
I'll wait for you.
No, no.
Don't do this to me.
Don't do this to me yet.
Okay.
Are you ready?
You ready?
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Come on, get tissue paper right now.
Wipe your hands.
We still have two more chapters.
We still have two more- Get tissue papers right now.
Wipe- get a towel.
Wipe your hands right now.
I'll pull you.
You go get a towel.
I'm gonna pull you.
You go get a- Oh my- you go get a towel.
I need to go pee.
Oh my god.
Get- get inside, get inside, get- Okay.
Go pee.
Go pee right now.
Oh my god.
Guys, we're gonna complete this.
We're gonna do this.
If it's the last thing I do, if it's the last.
Oh no.
Okay, okay.
She's still alive.
Okay.
Jesus Christ.
I'm gaming so hard right now.
We're literally at the end.
Oh my god.
Okay, how do we do this?
Oh, now I actually need her.
God damn it.
I actually need her now.
Okay.
Oh, I don't need her.
Wait a minute.
I actually don't need her.
Let's fucking go.
Let's- Okay, how do we- Alright.
Wait, how do we do this?
Oh!
There we go.
I didn't need her.
I did not need her at all.
Let's fucking go.
Wait, how do I- I don't untie this though.
Wait, how do you untie stuff?
Wait, no.
I need her.
Okay, that goes here.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
I figured it out.
Okay, I need her.
Oh, wait.
Wait, unless- Oh, I know.
I know.
Okay, we...
Okay.
Oh my god!
How is she still- How is she still- Oh my god!
Okay.
I don't need her.
I shall so- Oh, fuck.
Okay, I figured it out.
I figured out the pattern.
This.
This first.
Then this.
I don't need her.
I don't need anybody.
This is a solo mission right here.
Oh my god.
This is so stupid.
No!
Oh my god!
Come here!
I'm back!
You fucker!
Come here!
I had you!
I'm back!
I had a sister!
Of course!
Of course you threw my bee here!
Of fucking course!
Of fucking course you threw- I've been back for like two minutes.
Of fucking course- Look, I saved you!
I had a sister!
I can't- I can't believe it.
Look, I saved you.
I figured out the entire system.
And you just come back.
Just to fuck me over.
Look, I saved you again.
Oh my god.
God, seeing you is better than real you.
The funniest part is I think I've been back for a whole minute and a half watching you do it.
Oh my god, we did it!
We saved me!
At least I saved myself.
What the- There was another character in there.
Here we go.
Okay, we gotta go.
We gotta go.
I think it's gonna explode.
We gotta go fast.
Oh yeah.
Goodbye, I killed you first.
Thank god.
No, you're pink!
I'm yellow!
How do we get down?
Oh here.
That's fucking right.
I'll problem solve for us.
I died last.
Finally.
It's not like I literally problem solved the last puzzle.
Run.
We gotta run.
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, he's here.
He's here.
He's gonna touch you.
He's gonna touch your butt.
He's gonna do it.
He's gonna touch your butt right here.
Right there.
Right here.
What the fuck?
No, my hands are too cold.
He's coming to get you.
He's gonna get you.
Oh, no.
Look at that.
He's right there on your butt.
Right on your butt.
He's gonna poke you.
He's gonna be like...
Whoah!
Yeah.
And...
Oh, oh.
You slammed it to the wall.
I literally saw you slam it to the fucking wall.
Okay.
Get over here.
I'm gonna pull you.
Get over here, Gumi.
Get your ass over here.
Look, I saved you.
You did not save shit.
He's like...
Oh, my God.
Why did I follow you?
You should have been back at your parents' house.
I ran away for you.
Oh, my God.
What's going on?
What is the lore?
I don't know.
If you got your shiny thing, we'll figure out the lore.
Oh, it's this again.
Don't worry.
I did all of this before.
Okay, wait.
I fucked it up.
Okay.
This does that.
There you go.
You're fucking welcome.
Ow.
Why did you...
Why did...
I thought I was gonna pull you up.
I was waiting to pull you up.
No, no, we gotta be like...
Who the hell is messaging me?
They're not important because it's not me.
Okay.
Okay, don't...
I need to look at the...
Okay, this would be the last one.
I have to pull up.
Okay, and then...
Don't go anywhere.
I'm just saying.
Okay, this one.
Okay.
All right.
All right, let's do it.
Get it.
There we go.
See?
That...
There you go.
You're welcome.
That's what I was doing while you're in the bathroom.
Dude, I finished peeing really fast.
It's just I was talking to Kazu.
Oh my...
Bring Kazu!
You can talk to Kazu!
Oh, that's us.
You talk to Kazu while we're playing.
I'm tagging out.
No, he ran downstairs.
Could have been the host.
You could have been the host.
That's all I'm saying.
Wait, what are you doing?
Oh, wait.
Yeah, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
It's this way.
I hate you.
I don't know what she was doing, chat.
We did a parkour!
I don't even know how this machine works!
That's so dangerous.
Holy shit.
Be free!
Go back to your people!
And they're like, damn, I should have stayed home.
I miss my mom.
Oh, they're beefing!
Yeah!
Oh my god, finally it feels real.
Let's go.
Apparently, forklifts weigh more than a car?
Jeez, that's crazy.
I didn't know that.
Finally, this game is relatable now.
What chapter are we on?
We finished chapter five?
I've lost track, we've done so many.
Oh no, our friendship is broken!
You see that?
Listen, we had a good run.
It's broken now!
I think we had a good run.
Look!
I tried...
I was stuck, you tried to save me, and then I hated you.
No, you were stuck.
The pink is stuck.
Is pink stuck?
Yeah.
See?
Well, I guess we'll never know the rest of that story, because we're not doing that again.
Do you think we're gonna get a new friend?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we're at chapter...
Are we at chapter five?
What's that?
What's B1?
That's six?
We're at six.
Five is B.
Oh my god, we're almost there.
See?
We compliment each other.
I don't know roman numerals, you don't...
You know roman numerals.
Oh my god, stop.
Stop, stop, stop!
Stop picking the shiny!
Stop!
Stop, you picked up five shinies already!
Okay, and...
Why are we back in the woods?
Because we escaped the factory.
We were only in the factory because we got kidnapped.
Also, does that mean they went through the swamp?
I guess so.
Yeah.
Oh.
Tie it, and I think we pull it up.
And then you can...
Look, there's a shiny.
Where?
There's a shiny right there.
And then you pull up, you pull up, you...
You climb up, you climb up to the very top.
You climb up, you climb up.
Yes.
Yes, and then you keep climbing.
Go back a little, go back a little.
Go back a little.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You get one try, you get one try, you get one try.
There you go, yeah.
Is that what you wanted?
All right, now do...
Okay, okay.
There you go.
Everybody gets one.
Wall... Mog... Mog mortars.
Okay.
Here, jump.
Do the jumpies.
How do I do the wall jumpies?
The wall jumpies on the left.
I need to get up.
I need to get up first.
On the left.
Okay, you do it.
Okay.
JK, I don't need it.
What the...
Don't I still need to pull it down?
Wait, wait, I think...
Yeah, I pull it down and then...
Okay, I'll do it again.
What?
I think I have to pull it.
No, I have to.
No, I have to pull it.
Do I not?
No, it's my side.
I'm pretty sure, right?
You have to get off.
You have to get off the thing, I think.
Right?
No, that doesn't make sense.
If I get off, then I can't get up.
Unless you... Okay.
Yeah, yeah, see?
It's all right.
Did you tie it?
Yeah.
We had to tie it.
It's okay.
We can't all be special.
Yeah, we all can't.
I do not look like Pikmin.
How come you don't want me to...
That's why you get a good little star for today.
You know what?
Shut up.
This cuts in time.
It's my turn.
Look, I pissed at you.
Hey, I let you...
I carried you through that last puzzle.
It's my turn.
What?
Are you going pee?
Yeah, I'm gonna go pee.
Okay.
I see your Fuki moving.
Why is it moving?
Yeah, she can figure it out in a sec.
How do I get the shiny?
I know she's probably there.
Let me go through my photos and see which one I like the most.
All right, I'm back.
Why am I here?
Huh?
Why do I not carry me through this?
Well, because I knew you've been there.
What do you mean?
I just got back.
I went to the bathroom.
I saw your Fuki moving the entire time.
No, I muted it.
Yeah, and I muted myself.
So I could use the bathroom.
If you muted the Fuki, it wouldn't move, you freak.
What do you mean?
I muted myself.
What are you talking about?
Who the fuck...
Of course, I always mute myself when I use the bathroom.
Hey, I'm pretty sure this is like a time-sensitive level.
I'm pretty sure I...
Oh, yeah.
Hey, hey, um...
Should we be worried about that?
I don't know.
I'm pretty sure you have to go the other way.
I'm pretty sure you gotta tie that.
Hey, I think we're gonna burn.
I think we're gonna burn.
I think we're gonna...
Because I tied it, then what?
You didn't tie it.
No, you didn't.
Look.
Tied to what?
This.
Do you not see the loop on it?
That's a pink loop.
No, that's a yellow loop.
What?
You untied it!
Oh my god, I'm pretty sure I did.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we might as well just fucking burn.
Look, here, here.
See, look.
I did it.
You're supposed to be on the other side.
And then...
You know what?
I...
Because I'm selfless, I'll sacrifice myself for you.
Oh god bless, finally.
This has to be like the slowest fire though.
I'm pretty sure I just waited for it.
I think so too.
I think the fire was just like...
Any minute now, they go...
Huh?
Oh, wow.
I see you're not here to sacrifice yourself for the greater good.
I didn't think I needed to.
Oh, okay.
You're right.
I remember that.
Huh?
Oh, hey.
Yeah, whoa.
What happened?
What happened over there, huh?
Oh, I happened to risk four times.
Oh, what do you mean?
I don't know.
I feel like something happened.
Four times?
Are you talking about yourself?
No, I'm talking about something that I watched earlier.
What did you watch?
I was in the bathroom, so I don't know what you're talking about.
How are you supposed to do that?
Oh!
We did it.
Wait, what?
Oh, we just need to jump higher.
Don't start forest fires, guys.
How did this fire start again?
I don't know.
I think it could be you.
It could be anybody, honestly, but it's definitely not me.
You mean it?
Yeah.
What's that rope for?
Oh.
Yeah, go down.
Oh, I didn't want to swing anymore, mom.
You are the best swinger.
I don't think you should say things like that.
Get up, get up.
You're the best swinger I know.
You know what?
I went on a cruise.
Yeah?
Anyways.
Oh, yeah, keep going.
Go away.
No, you got to stop that story there.
What's wrong with some of the story?
What did you do at the cruise?
I didn't do nothing, but I saw... I saw things.
Wait, what?
Wait, isn't that Cruise of Minecrafters?
Yeah, but no, there's not only minecrafters on the like thousand people cruise line.
Oh, shit.
You mean there's non minecrafters?
No, there was a lot of old people who were also racist.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean?
Wait, wait, what do you mean by what did you see other crews?
There were people with specific stickers that said they were down to swing, you know?
Oh.
So the minecrafters were in a swing cruise, is that what you're trying to say?
No.
Wait, yeah, people use stickers for that?
Yeah.
Let me... They're gonna touch us.
Oh my God, I keep falling, because I'm holding down.
The grass will keep me safe.
Wait, wait, stop, stop, stop.
I want to see if the grass keeps it safe.
It does, it does, it does.
Does it?
Yeah.
Does it actually not come all the way down?
No, it doesn't, because it's like they don't like to touch grass.
I told you this like three hours ago.
Look, see?
Oh, why did you activate that?
Why did you?
Why?
Gumi, why did you activate that?
Okay.
Stop!
Okay, we gotta do this fast.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Gumi.
Gumi!
I'm like, Gumi!
Get over here!
I'm like holding a fucking leash right now!
He has over here!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Doesn't he have a baby leash?
Yeah, you're a fucking... yeah, you're a big baby.
And I mean it.
Yeah.
Derogatory.
What?
What are you doing?
I have to climb up!
Look, it's on me.
It's on me now.
It's literally... yes, look, look, he's... okay.
Okay, now, now, whoa, whoa, whoa, now it's on me again!
Now, whoa, I'm saving your life!
I need you to bait it.
All right, I baited it, I baited it.
I'm baiting it, I'm heading over to bait it right now.
I'm baiting it, I'm baiting it.
All right, okay.
Okay.
Gumi, Gumi, Gumi, you didn't even bait it!
You didn't even bait it!
Why did you?
Why didn't you bait it?
I was wondering what you were doing down there.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Gumi, you gotta wait!
You gotta be patient!
I'm impatient!
Okay, all right, all right, all right, all right, all right.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, I'm dead!
Okay, now what?
I climb up.
That's all we had to do.
Now what?
That we climb up.
You could have just pulled...
Oh my god, go, go, go, go, go.
The forest is on fire.
Just go, just go, just go, just go!
Go, go!
Stop!
Stop looking at the seed!
We're all dying!
Oh my god.
Oh,
now you go.
Now that...
Oh my god.
Oh, you bitch.
We're literally dying.
We're literally...
Oh my god, hot, hot, hot, hot!
Oh my god.
Okay,
we figured it out.
What?
What do you mean, we?
We figured it out.
Oh, we figured it out.
You like...
Dude.
Oh my god, how do you swing that?
I think...
That's only for the secret, isn't it?
What?
Did I get it?
Because we could have gone on the floor, no?
No, we can't.
There's a lower branch.
Yeah, you saw that?
Whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
Jesus Christ, the momentum is crazy.
Stopping the momentum at this point.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
My little tootsie.
No, no, no, no, no.
My feet.
Okay, I'm good.
Don't die.
Don't die!
Get in, get in, get in, get in.
One person.
I think this is a one-person job.
I think that was the issue.
Things were so much simpler when we were just one person.
Wow.
Okay, we gotta do that and then...
There you go.
Things are simpler.
Get on.
You were not trying hard enough.
All right, get off.
Now we both did one puzzle each?
Life can be so beautiful.
Oh.
Are you ready?
Okay.
All right, he did...
All right.
Just go straight at it.
Don't even be like, yeah, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
Oh my god.
I felt like a fire pit.
I think we're supposed to stay on this.
I think so too.
Oh!
Oh, hot!
Oh, my feet!
What happened, Gumi?
I thought you were a gamer.
What happened?
Gumi, you okay?
Maybe this time you'd get it.
Yeah, see?
Look, you got it.
All right, come on.
Come on, come on.
Here, boy.
Come on.
Use your own feet, you bitch.
What the...
Don't go, don't go.
Don't go all the way there.
Come on, I'm pulling you.
Come on, come on.
Pulling you.
Hot, hot, hot!
All right.
I think you controlled my volume too, so the game got so loud.
No, I didn't.
I didn't do anything.
No, no, I meant earlier, and I just never adjusted it back.
Yeah, I was gonna say, like, what do you mean?
I didn't adjust anything.
No!
Oh, we have to stay.
We do not stay on it?
No.
Wait, what?
How do we...
Oh!
It happened so fast.
No, I could just stay on it.
What do you mean?
Why would I jump back on it?
I literally stood on it.
You okay there?
You okay over there?
Yeah.
I was just showing you what you did.
Yeah, I was like, oh, she's so stupid.
You get one.
How would you think you're gonna get it?
Wait, it's not even a shiny.
It's a puzzle we need to do.
How do we do this puzzle?
Oh.
You pushing it?
Row, row, row, row, row, row.
Okay, your turn.
Think.
Wait, what's that flower thing over there?
Oh!
Maybe you can use that as a momentum?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, no, no, no!
I got an idea!
Oh.
Wait.
Can you pull this up?
Oh, never mind.
I was gonna say...
Is there a way to...
Pull this up higher so you can use as a momentum?
So we have to use as momentum, right?
Oh, there you go.
You're welcome.
And then what?
What do you do with that?
No, dang it.
Oh!
I know.
Wait, why did you let go?
Why did you do that?
I untied the wrong string.
Oh my god, there's kids in the background!
Oh, they're...
What are they doing?
Oh, they're trying to lift the wood!
Do you need help?
I went too early.
Do you need help there?
No.
You sure?
Okay.
Oh, you're doing it?
Oh, if you tie it, if you tie it, I can like pull it.
Yeah, see?
Wait, where am I?
Where did I go?
Oh wait, here I am.
What the fuck?
How did I get here?
Wait a minute, how did I get over here?
Wait, wait, what?
How do I...
How did I get here?
What the fuck?
I was like wondering where I went.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
I don't know.
Wait, can't I...
Can't I just swing on the other side if you keep it taut?
Wait, wait, wait, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh yeah, there you go.
And then pull.
And then pull?
Yeah, pull.
I'm not letting you...
I'm pulling?
I think because you're at the bottom, I think.
Oh no, you...
Oh my god.
Oh no, I'm back here.
Is it because my string's attached to it?
No, it can't be.
No, no, no.
You gotta go to the other side again.
It's because you were too heavy on the other side, so you have to go back downstairs.
What is this string for down here?
I don't know.
Because it keeps it like that.
I don't think...
Oh, will you tie it down?
Oh, maybe I tie it down?
Oh, oh, I know, I know, I know.
I go on the other side and then tie it down after.
Yeah, you untie it.
I figured it out, I figured it out.
Okay, but not like that.
Alright, so you do that thing.
I've done that one too many times.
Okay, I figured it out, I figured it out.
I can tie it on my end.
Then you swing to the other side.
You loop around.
You just gotta swing to the other.
How did you do it?
How did you swing to the other side?
You're too heavy, so I can't move it up.
So you have to...
Yeah, there you go.
Yeah, yeah, you have to...
You have to be up top more and then...
Because I can't push it up.
I think I need you to stop moving because you're changing the length of my rope.
Oh.
How did you do it last time?
I don't know.
Oh wait, maybe...
Oh, just pull up here.
Can't you just...
Yeah, that's how you did it.
And then all I have to do is just...
Tie it here.
Oh.
You untied it.
I pressed the wrong button.
Okay, you gotta do that again, but we figured it out.
Wait, I need to get back to the top.
I need to get back up here.
Okay, there you go.
I forgot B is untie on my controller.
A is untie for me.
No, B.
B is untie for me.
No, I'm saying A is untie for me.
And then you just...
Oh, you have to do that and then you just...
Yeah.
And then I just go over here and then...
Can you go up a little bit?
Oh yeah, I did it.
And then...
Do you untie that?
Untie it?
Untie the other... the top part, right?
Why would I untie the top part?
I don't know.
Because we're trying to pull it down.
Yeah, so we untie that.
We're gonna be...
Okay, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I'm gonna untie it.
Okay.
Because I fucked up.
I hooked up.
Yeah, do it again.
Oh, do I untie my thing first?
Maybe?
You better untie this first.
Yeah.
Wait, I...
No, no, no.
Can you go under?
I can't.
Jump down?
Like...
Press down and jump?
I can't because this...
Yeah, this thing is blocking me.
So I need you to let go so I can jump down.
Ew.
My brain hurts.
We're gonna be stuck in this burning forest and then die from the lack of air.
Look, I have a wedgie.
No, you're Spongebob.
You're literally Spongebob right now.
Get down!
I can't!
I'm out of string!
I can't do anything!
Okay, wait, I got an idea.
There.
You should have your string now.
Do you not have string?
No, this is as much string as I have.
How do I get back up?
All right, here we go.
Go.
Okay.
I gave you string.
Yeah, I had to.
To give you string.
Ew.
I get...
oh.
Yeah, it's tied.
Okay, wait.
Yeah, you push out.
Push it, push it.
Just push out above me.
Okay.
I'm literally pushing it the only way that I can and it's flopping back down.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
All right, I tied it.
Hello.
Let go.
Let go!
I don't think this is it.
I don't think so either.
Why did we do it again?
I don't know.
I'm following your lead, but like...
Why are you following my lead?
I'm not the only one here.
I don't know how to solve puzzles.
Why are you following...
Do the thing!
Now what do we do?
I tied it.
Oh, wait.
I got an idea.
Okay, you do your thing.
What thing?
Wait, I got an idea.
I figured it out.
You do your thing.
You do that thing where you...
I have to make it go down!
No, no, you do your thing.
You do your...
I figured it out.
I think my brain...
My brain is...
Whoa.
Whoa, it's expanding.
It's expanding.
I figured it out.
I know, I know.
I know now.
I need one more rope and I can't move from this area.
Do your thing.
I figured it out.
Do your thing!
I have no more rope.
I don't know what to do for you.
It's because you tied it.
Don't tie it.
Let go.
Why did you tie that one?
I figured it out.
I know, I know.
Do your thing!
Watch this!
Get on there!
This is...
It won't let me go lower.
No, how did you do the thing where you get to the other side?
I'm not...
I just need you to know that...
Okay.
Do your thing!
I figured it out!
It's gonna be so cool when you see it.
Why won't it let me go lower anymore?
I don't fucking know.
I'm not pulling anything either.
I'm letting you have...
I'm letting you have all the strength.
Do you remember how to do it?
I'm pressing down on the climb button!
Maybe you're like...
I don't know.
I'm literally just watching you.
I think our string is broken.
No!
I figured it!
I figured out I need you to do your thing!
That's all I need!
I literally figured it out!
I just need you to do your thing!
What happened to your string?
I don't know what to tell you.
It's...
Oh my god!
It's so cool!
The idea I had!
I swear!
It's basically it!
It's it!
It's the idea!
Okay, all right.
We swap places.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Okay, okay.
Watch this.
I need you to...
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Watch this.
I figured it out.
Yes.
Yeah.
Okay.
I don't have enough string to get it.
No, I was...
I was gonna let go.
I was gonna...
We almost had it.
You stay right there.
Okay, I'm gonna let go.
I don't know how you're gonna get there, but like, I'm gonna let go.
I don't know.
I don't know how you're gonna get to the other side.
But I'm gonna watch.
I'm gonna watch.
Oh my god.
This has to be the longest.
Yes.
Did I just do this other time?
Here, all right.
I have the word here if you want to use it.
Here it is.
Okay.
Guys, we're gonna be here for a little bit.
I don't understand why it's taking you...
Making it so difficult for you.
Okay, why don't we swap?
All right, all right, all right.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
I'm trying to get back up.
All right, all right, let's go.
All right, I'm pulling you up.
I'm pulling you up.
All right, let's swap.
All right, let's go.
How is this puzzle the hardest puzzle we've ever done?
How could this one be the hardest?
So how did you get all the way down though?
There you go.
Oh wait, I did that.
Oh wait, I actually did that.
Oh my god.
This is it.
We figured it out, guys.
We figured it out.
I really want like Taiwanese beef noodle soup.
There you go.
I did it.
Okay, now what?
Now shouldn't you come over and tie it and like push me up?
No, no, no, at the bottom.
At the bottom of the tree stump.
We figured it out, guys.
This is it.
This is it right here.
All right, now I'm gonna let go.
I'm gonna um...
Yeah, maybe tie at the bottom first, right?
Yeah.
Well, okay.
But do you have enough?
You gotta pull the string up so you can tie the bottom.
And then you like, maybe like after you push it up, you tie it.
I think we're making this much more complicated than it should be.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah, no, I agree.
You can't just tie the string there.
We're definitely making this much more...
Yeah, I went up.
How is this the hardest puzzle yet?
I don't understand.
I don't understand, I'm just confused.
The hardest puzzle we've done.
What do I do?
Maybe here?
What?
You're just scaring me, that's all.
Maybe you tie there?
Okay, and then what?
I don't fucking know.
And then maybe...
Maybe, oh, bring the wood?
Yeah.
Ready?
The wood left without me.
I mean, technically.
You didn't tie it, by the way, you didn't.
Well, I can't jump up and...
Oh, all right.
Now I'm Spongebob.
Press F for hint?
No, no, no hints!
I think I figured it out, I think I figured it out.
I think I know.
Just gotta get to the other side.
How did you get to the other side?
I forgot.
You swung over the top.
Okay, here.
Weeeew!
Oh my god!
I definitely figured it out this time, I swear.
Okay, no, no, I almost got to the other side.
There you go, and then you fling me, you fling me across, you fling me across, yes.
You fling me across.
I'm gonna let go, and then you're gonna give me momentum right here.
Okay.
Okay, well that's all momentum you're getting.
Okay, Spongebob.
I give up.
No, I don't wanna be here again.
I don't know anymore.
I thought I figured it out.
I thought you were supposed to be the smart one out of us.
I'm tired!
We have one chapter left!
All right.
Oh, I get it.
I get it now.
You said that earlier.
Yeah, but I get it for real.
Okay.
I get it for real now.
Oh no, no, no, no, you were so close!
It's my turn.
Okay, now fling me.
The flinging's not gonna work!
No, it's gonna work, I swear.
I swear!
Now fling me.
Fling me.
There's a loop from the left stump?
Where's the loop?
Guys, guys, we're gonna phone a friend.
Guys, we...
Wait, wait, wait!
Could push up that?
What is that?
No.
Wait, what's that for?
What's what for?
What was that for?
What's going on?
I don't know anymore.
I'm sad.
Can I jump from the top of the sign?
What sign?
Oh,
I did it!
I did
it!
I get it.
I definitely got it this time.
Wait.
Okay.
Okay, and then...
Wait, how is it?
Are you also tied to it?
Oh, you are.
Okay, and then...
And then I do...
Ta-da!
I told you I got it.
Wait, but I didn't get a chance to do this part.
I didn't...
We need me to loop first.
I didn't get a chance to loop.
I didn't get a chance to loop the other side.
Get out!
I forgot to loop!
We forgot to loop!
Get over here!
I needed to loop.
Get out!
Get over here!
I need to loop!
Wait, I didn't need to, JK.
Get over here!
JK, I just went from under.
No,
no, no.
That's not true.
There, go do your thing!
Do your thing!
You got it!
Go over here!
Get over here!
You gotta be on the other side.
Are you ready?
Okay.
We literally figured it out!
How did you not get this swing correct?
We literally figured it out, Gumi.
We literally figured it out.
We figured it out.
Ta-da!
Let's just keep pulling in, please.
Oh my god, I don't wanna...
Oh my god.
Where am I?
I thought I could go up.
I told you, you couldn't!
Oh, whoops!
I told you I didn't bring you up there first!
All right, that's fine.
We figured it out.
All right, now we do this together.
I figured out the initial solution, though.
Yeah, I meant...
Wait, I don't think we're...
Okay, wait, wait.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, wait.
JK, I got it.
You do your thing first, and then I'll come over.
You do your thing first.
We figured out the solution, though.
All right, now my turn.
Wait, do you have to get to the other side first?
Maybe you should get...
Well, I can't get to the other side unless...
Should I come down?
You want me to come down?
I think the forest is burned down.
I think the forest is gone.
There's no forest left.
There's no...
I technically figured it out.
Yeah, I think...
I don't think we have this forest no more.
Why do you do that?
Now how are you gonna get to...
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
What are you doing?
Untie it.
You just gotta flip it over.
New forests will grow by the time they figure out this puzzle.
Oh, there you go.
See, look, you're doing it.
Just gotta climb.
Can you...
Can you pull it, please?
Can you pull it?
Can you pull...
Nooo!
I'm pulling a map...
A map...
A map trick.
I need you to go higher.
I need you to untie that, so I can go down.
I need you to- the moment I untie this, it's all- I need you- okay, there we go.
There we go.
So how do we do this now?
Um.
Oh wait, I got an idea.
I have an idea.
Just chill.
And then...
You shouldn't have untied that.
I'm having a good time.
Yeah, let's go!
No.
Yeah, see, it was just that easy.
Okay, the moment- you better untie it after that, right?
I don't think so.
I must untie it here, right?
No, don't!
Like, untie mid-slide.
I'm pulling as much as I could down here right now.
Do it.
I believe.
I believe the mid-slide.
I believe this is it.
Oh, JK, I didn't need to do the- wait, wait, wait.
Unless...
No, I can't tie it, guys, because- because, like, I don't know if I'm gonna be able to untie it.
I don't have enough string.
This is it.
Aww.
All I was saying is you should have untied it mid-swing.
I believe.
I believe in you.
I believe in you, Gumi.
Oh, I figured it out.
You said that, like, three times.
I'm untying it.
I figured it out for real, though.
Okay, push it.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
I need- I- okay, let's do that again.
Okay, do it.
How much string do I get?
How much string do I get from this?
That's not a lot of string.
Wait.
Wait, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
I need- I'm thinking.
Maybe I might tie this.
Oh, okay.
Get on the stump.
Oh, wait.
What if I just- wait.
All right.
Hello.
Hey, you enjoying your life here?
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Here we go, here we go, here we go, here we go.
Oh, hey.
Now I'm trapped.
What if I do this?
And then...
That's the same thing that you just did and you're so unexpectable!
Okay.
Okay, but what if I- but what if I do this?
What if I do that, you see?
And then you push, push it, push it.
Wait, how come I can't move more?
Wait, why did you do that?
Wait, wait.
Tie it?
Yeah, but I don't have enough.
I don't have enough now.
I don't have enough.
What do I do?
What about me?
Can you try getting up here?
Oh, hey, I could swing all the way back there.
Wait.
No, I can't.
For me.
Get up here.
How?
Hello.
Oh, hey.
No, we can't.
Why did we swap places?
Okay,
I'm gonna set up the thingy for you.
Okay.
It's held down for you now.
What do I do?
What do you want me to do?
Jump over?
So...
Well...
You mean?
Yeah.
And that's all I have.
And then you can go up.
Get on though.
And tie it again.
Can you go around?
Yeah.
Hello.
Yeah?
Okay, I need you to come all the way over here.
Okay.
Can you jump on the top of that right here?
Yeah.
And then grab onto the thingy.
I think you're making it unnecessarily more complicated.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I think that's the closest we've ever gotten.
Wait, wait, wait, I think we... I got it, I got it.
Okay, and then I'll let go after that.
So then you'd have more...
After you do your thing.
I don't think letting go is the answer.
No, to give you more string.
I'm gonna let go so you get more string.
Right?
Because you didn't have enough string, right?
And then I'll let go and then...
Oh my god, oh my god, we did it.
We...
Was that even the right answer?
Like, did we brute force that?
I'm pretty sure it was.
I'm pretty sure it was the right answer.
We made it out.
I reached a point in my head of clarity.
I like, went into nirvana or something.
No, we brute forced it.
We actually brute forced it.
That wasn't even the solution.
We'll never know what the real answer was.
We'll never know.
What?
Wait, you watched a YouTube video?
No, no, I'm asking, can we...
Yeah, yeah, we'll see.
Let's watch the YouTube video and see what the real...
Oh my god, what was the real answer?
Wait, we both...
You can't grasp on me or like...
We have to both get that.
Or we...
We can't swing, I think.
What are you doing?
Wait, what?
Or maybe I have to be there for you.
Right?
I don't know.
Here, go.
Woo!
Yeah, but how about you?
Why are you going so far away?
There we go, we did it!
I can't believe we brute-forced that.
It's actually crazy.
Wait, how come I can't get that jump?
There you go.
I did it.
Oh, okay, here.
Wait, what?
No, I think you just swing on my side, right?
Just swing.
I'll hold you.
Oh, too low.
Okay.
I'm holding.
I'm still holding.
Okay.
Hold.
I'm literally not holding any other button.
Hold!
I think you have to let go when I get over here.
Do it.
Let go!
I did it.
Then what do I do?
Oh, you gotta hit that.
Hey, see?
Look at that!
See, the forest is still okay.
I don't think it looks very okay.
The forest is still okay.
We might...
Kumi, I just want you to know that...
We gotta work together for this.
That puzzle took us an hour.
Wait, how do we get there?
Oh, you just swing.
My turn!
Woooooooo!
I don't think...
Oh, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah, woah.
Get in, get in!
Okay.
How do we do this?
Get out.
Okay.
My turn!
Woooooo!
Your turn.
My turn!
Yippee!
This is a great game.
I'm glad you suggested this.
Oh my god!
Oh my god, there's a meese!
Why are you so slow?
Why?
Cuz you got a lot of momentum from swinging forward!
How did you walk over?
Wow!
Whoops.
I got a little too excited.
Why didn't it get into the...
Why didn't it get into the cabin?
I don't understand.
There's like nothing inside there that's important, right?
Oh.
I think because there's no other way out.
Oh, maybe.
That's why they're going on the other side.
I see now.
Ah!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
My wife's got me.
All right.
Oh!
No,
it's not.
No, it's not.
See, we're fine.
Oh, it's not.
No, it's coming over.
We're not fine.
It's heading over.
Take the jump.
Make the jump of faith.
Go, go, go, go, go.
We got...
We lost some...
We lost some time.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we lost time.
We got our speed run.
We lost time from our speed run because...
Go, go, go, go, go, go.
Wait, what?
What?
Oh, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull, pull.
Do not pull that.
No, you have to get on...
And then you swing over to that second one.
Oh!
Oh, this fire is gonna kill us.
And then what?
Oh!
Oh, shit.
We did it.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Nice.
Look, look at that.
Saving time.
We're saving time.
No, free the horses!
Somebody free the horses!
The shiny!
Somebody free...
The horse is more important!
Quick, quick, quick!
We gotta save the horse!
What do we do after that?
Oh!
What the fuck?
We scare the horses?
Oh!
Wait, what?
Oh, you might...
We gotta figure out how to...
No, not...
No.
We gotta push the hose.
How do we push the hose?
Yeah, yeah, drop.
Oh, there it is!
Use the momentum!
We did it!
Oh, that's what the children were doing!
They were trying to save the horses!
Wow!
Those are good kids.
Good kids.
And there's us.
Shiny!
We did it!
We saved the horse to save the world!
We'll never know what the...
Another chapter has to be a short one, right?
Because we did it.
We saved everything.
Honestly, I think if we did not get stuck in that one puzzle...
We would have finished the game a lot earlier.
It's always that one puzzle.
That one puzzle really fucked us up.
Oh my god!
Last...
Last chapter!
They're closed?
Oh my god, what day is today?
It's Tuesday.
I don't know why, but a lot of Asian restaurants near me close on Tuesdays.
That's weird.
I thought they'd be open later, because usually they are.
It's aren't they?
It's definitely Tuesdays.
Maybe it's like a break day on Tuesday.
Up, up, up, up.
Up, goomy up.
Last chapter.
Oh, whoa, whoa.
You fucking went in without me.
Oh my god, we can be in 11th place on the leaderboards!
For the speedrun!
Wow!
Oh, it does, yeah.
Look shiny!
All right, your last shiny of the day.
God, I wish I could cut the rope.
Cut the rope?
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna cut the rope.
Look, see?
I told you.
The forest fire stopped.
We did it.
Don't be dis...
Oh.
How was I supposed to know?
Okay, that's on you.
I stopped.
I stopped after that.
Here.
It's literally that easy.
It's...
My momentum.
My momentum!
It's on you.
I guess you'll just drown.
And then, we have to do it again.
Oh my god, this is on you.
This is on you.
This is...
That was on you.
I had the momentum.
Right there.
I died...
There you go.
That's how you do it.
I...
We gotta work...
We gotta work together.
It's easier.
It's...
You're...
You're literally better at this than me.
How?
Oh, I think...
I think you're better at it.
Than me.
You're lucky.
Oh my god, you're lucky.
I want to finish this game.
It looks like...
It looks like I'm not better.
Oh, I got stuck on the first one.
Your turn.
I guess...
I guess we just gotta do it ourselves.
Oh.
What the fuck is the story?
There's a fire.
I fucking...
I don't know.
I thought you'd be...
Everyone knows I don't pay attention that much.
Whoa.
Oh, they're still chasing after the kids?
Bro, I would too if they burned down entire place.
I mean, to be fair, yeah.
Like, they're literally criminals at that point.
Those children are criminals.
We gotta get them.
What's this?
Oh.
Okay.
I can't push it no more.
That's the most I can push.
Oh, then we'll jump that side?
No.
I can only push it like this.
Uh...
Yeah, you still have to wall jump.
Go under?
Or well...
No.
But that's good enough.
Okay, well now...
No.
Oh, oh, I get it.
Okay, and then...
I get it.
Oh, I already...
Then what?
Okay.
Then what do I do?
Yeah?
Uh...
Maybe like...
Okay, wait.
Maybe we do loop it.
Do we loop it?
Oh, wait.
I got it.
Wait.
Wait, no.
You go back to the other side and I'll pull it.
Can I pull you?
Okay.
Whoa!
This is bad.
Maybe do this side.
Well, it has to be over.
The rope has to be over for you to pull me up.
Oh, you're right.
Why'd you go on this side?
I don't know.
All right.
Oh, there you go.
We did it.
Can you pull me up?
Oh, wait.
Push it?
Yeah.
Oh.
My rope's gonna get tangled.
Is it tangled?
Yeah, my rope is gonna get tangled.
Oh.
Then...
What do I do?
Pull me.
Oh, okay.
What's this then?
What's this for?
Oh.
What's that for then?
Hold on.
No, you need to push it.
No, you gotta push this.
You gotta push it.
Yeah, and then I'll pull you back up.
I need to pull you back up.
I need to pull you up, I think.
Yeah.
Okay, then what does that do?
We have this.
Watch him pop the wheel thingy.
Where's the wheel thingy?
Up there.
Oh, there's a wheel thingy up here.
Okay.
Okay, we need to push it.
We need to push it again.
Okay.
I'm gonna stand on it and you push it.
Push what?
This?
Yeah.
Yeah, because...
No.
No, it goes with the wheel.
The wheel needs to be closer to the left wall.
No.
I'll stand on it.
I feel like...
Okay, now stand on it.
Now stand...
Go up.
Go up and now stand on the button.
I did it.
Oh,
look, see?
It turns.
Maybe we, like, do that.
Let it turn and then...
Look.
Wait, I think I know.
I think I know.
Okay.
And we gotta push this back.
And then you loop it, don't you?
You loop that, I wonder.
What do we do with this?
What the fuck?
Yeah, I'm just wondering where loop's at.
How do we loop that?
I'll stand.
We push that...
No, we can't push that even more.
That's the thing.
I'm just wondering if we could get it to the other side.
Maybe we...
Put it at the end?
Put it at the end.
No, put it at the end and then we push it up.
No, like, at the...
Let it roll all the way.
How come?
Because, like, why is the knob all the way over there now?
Press the button.
Oh, oh, oh!
Don't do this to me!
It went all the way, it went all the way.
Okay.
Ta-da!
I did it!
Yippie!
Then, we just gotta push this.
We gotta push this and then you just keep pushing the button, so...
Push it.
Yeah, and then I'll push it.
And then...
Oh, you have to be off the button.
Yeah.
Okay, keep it there.
Don't, you don't need to do anything more.
I did it!
I'm so smart.
What did you think I meant earlier when I was asking you to push the button?
Yippie!
I did it!
I figured out the solution, chat.
It was all me.
I figured out the solution.
Oh, oh, are you okay over there?
Where's the thing?
Oh, it's over here.
Okay, where do I go?
Oh.
Here?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Here we go.
I go here and then I go here.
And then we put, push this here.
Hold on, I need you on the other side.
I need you on, oh, okay.
You need to push that.
And then I push this.
Yeah, we did it!
And then we gotta go downstairs, I think.
Yeah.
Don't get crushed.
And what, here?
And you go on the other side, you push the other.
There's a lever on the other.
Is there not a lever on the other side?
Oh, there, never mind.
Yay!
Yay, yay, yay!
Get back up here.
Wall jump right side, wall jump right side.
Here, I'm going to stand on it, you wall jump right side.
Yay!
Okay, we have to wait up there.
Got you.
All right, and then...
Yay!
We need to push it.
Oh, and less.
Oh, shit!
Koby!
I don't think that's what Koby means!
I hit the shot.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Try jumping on now.
Go.
Well, let go.
Let go first?
No.
Wait, why didn't you let go?
I did, and then you ran back!
Didn't work.
I think it was supposed to be on that side.
I think...
I think it was this...
This side.
Yay!
No, you have to come to me.
Come to me, come to me.
Yeah, no, you have to raise...
No, no, no, no, no, you didn't raise...
You didn't raise it enough.
No, you...
Stay right here.
Yippee!
Because then my rope's going that way.
Oh, yeah.
I'm so smart.
Oh.
Yay!
Wait, maybe?
There we go.
We did it!
Dude, what is...
What are these kids doing, bro?
No, we should arrest these children.
This is not...
We're releasing the floodgates?
Save the forest!
We're saved!
The forest is already break down!
We're already flooding it!
This is not good.
We're actually gonna flood a village.
We're gonna destroy a village!
Oh my god!
We're destroying the ecosystem!
Oh.
I guess I'll just stop existing.
All right.
I drowned.
These kids are terraforming.
Oh!
Wait, we have double jump!
We have double jump!
You know, you could've told me we had double jump before letting me drown, you know?
You knew we had double jump.
Somebody let me drown.
It's all right.
They have a license to terraform, clearly.
Oh, the music is really good though.
No, no, no, no, no.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
Um...
It's fine.
Did you not read the note?
No, what did it say?
It said...
You double jump recharges off walls.
Oh, look!
Oh!
How the fuck did they not drown?
I don't know.
They're fucking stupid as hell.
You double jump to what?
If you wall jump, you can double jump recharge off of it.
Oh!
You know, I don't read.
All right, here you go.
Here's the recharge.
Here we go.
You're welcome.
Let's go, let's go, let's go.
We need the momentum!
Come on!
Keep up!
I can't see.
Oh my god!
Get in, get in, get in!
Get in!
Perfect timing!
I got a message!
Get in!
We got a message.
Are you fucking...
Who are you texting?
I don't know.
Maybe my 6 p.m.
I believe it.
We die.
Oh my god, wait.
Why is there fire here?
Okay.
It's a leftover ashes.
That's what the flood was for!
Oh my god.
Jeez, what's the point of flooding the whole entire village if...
If there's still gonna be fire?
I don't know.
These kids are fucking evil.
Yeah, I know, right?
It's like they're gonna ruin an entire village and...
And it doesn't even matter anyway.
Like...
All of this was for nothing?
Wait, how the fuck do I...
Can I just jump over that?
Oh yeah, I do.
I didn't see that.
It's fine, we're fine.
Alright, now you're on your own.
Now it's just water.
Nope.
You were too slow.
If you were faster...
If you were faster, you might have got the shiny.
You were too slow.
Oh wait, what?
Okay, just relax.
Oh, let's look into the construction site.
Oh!
Oh, what?
Oh my
god!
Now the children are murderers?!
Holy shit!
What is this fucking story?
Holy shit, there's literally...
I can't...
There's literally like fire in the water!
There's like lava!
There's like fire!
That was so...
That was out of nowhere!
To be fair, the children already committed so much...
So many crimes.
Like, this is just one more crime.
And they're underage, so they're just going to juvie.
They're not going to actual jail.
So like, they commit as many crimes as they want.
What?
No...
No, that's on you.
I didn't even stop you there.
Right?
Where did the adults go?
Children, where did they go?
They're taking a boat now?
Like, how did...
Oh my god!
What is that?
Who's that guy?
Did they just kill another man?
Did they push another man?
Did they just push another guy into the water?
That's...
I don't understand kids anymore.
I...
They're going off the grid.
They know what crime they committed.
They gotta go...
What are you doing?
It's right here.
How do we do this?
Oh, okay.
That's how.
It's fucking where I see you.
Trying to mooch off.
Oh my god.
Gumi.
Gumi, what's going on?
I like...
I started forgetting the controls at some point.
Gumi,
please.
Please!
She'll let me stay on.
Oh, man.
Wow.
Okay, Mao.
Now it's my turn.
Oh, yep.
All right.
Untangle yourself now.
All right, let's go.
Nice.
Oh my god.
We're like fucking salmon.
Gotta go to the top of the lake so we can make babies.
Let's go.
That's the reason why.
That's the only thing that's going in their head.
Yeah, gotta go up this lake so I can...
So I can pee on some eggs.
Let's go!
All right, let's go.
That's how babies are born, chat.
The mama...
Yeah, the mama poops some eggs out and then the papa pee on the eggs and then...
Wait, wait, wait.
What's happening?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they're alive!
They're like, oh, he's alive!
Oh no, they're alive!
No!
No, we fucked up!
We didn't finish the job.
It's over.
Now they...
Now there's evidence.
Should've finished...
Didn't get rid of the witness, guys.
Oh no, no.
They should've finished the job when they had the chance.
Now, now they're alive.
Now they're alive.
I think we gotta go right, right side.
Wait, what?
Oh.
You do your stuff first and then...
Okay, that's, that's fine.
That, that's fine.
I waited for you, but you don't have to wait for me.
That's, that's okay.
Wait, is this?
Okay.
I drowned.
My turn.
Oh.
Okay, wait, let me die first.
My turn.
Yay.
Yippee.
Now I'm the special little boy.
Yay.
Oh.
I'm the passenger prince.
What?
I think you like gotta swing.
Maybe you gotta swing up.
And yeah, you see that tree bark that's yellow?
That's when you can like climb on it.
The music just got really loud.
Yeah, it did.
Um...
Yay.
Where the fuck are we going?
Do we go left or right?
We're going home.
I think we're going right.
Mom.
Yippee.
Oh, are we actually going home?
Oh shit, it's night time.
Dude, now what?
Now what?
Yeah.
We committed so much crime.
What if they catch us?
Oh, that's her parents.
They're mad.
Do you think they know we committed eco-terrorism?
I don't know, maybe.
Do you think they know?
We'll never find out.
Are we gonna go to Juvie?
Hey, at least we're gonna go to Juvie together.
And attempted murder too.
Whoa!
When did they get Kingdom Hearts?
Yeah, what the?
Why are the heartless here?
Open your heart to darkness.
Sora.
What the fuck?
Oh, wait.
Who the fuck are these guys?
Wait, there's others?
There's all of us.
There's others?
And I settled with you?
Wait, that's...
My yellow one has a really cute ear.
You son of a bitch.
Let's see what my yellow one is.
I like the short ears.
Yeah, yeah, the short ears are cute.
He ordered me dinner.
What the fuck?
Thank god there's others.
I can't decide on what I want.
I'm having a hard time deciding what I want now.
Why not?
Why?
Just order...
Just order Chinese food.
I don't want Chinese food.
Oh my god, now we have to read this.
Love, okay.
Love forms bonds between us...
but not to hold us back.
They're meant to save us if we fall or help us climb higher.
Yes, things break beyond repair sometimes, but we can always build anew.
If our fire ever fades, it just takes a single spark to set it off again.
No matter how dark things get, we can all help light the way.
We can make this life beautiful for ourselves and for each other.
And we all deserve to be here.
Whatever shape or color we come in.
Hey, thank you for playing Rival 2.
We hope you enjoyed it.
We did it, guys!
I'm pretty sure those children are gonna go to jail.
There's our duty.
Yeah, I don't know what the fucking lore was.
I feel like...
I mean, like, we hated our parents...
and then, like, we ran away...
and somehow we committed...
Lots of crime.
We committed a lot of crime.
Oh, there you are.
Hey.
Yeah, I don't know what any of these paintings mean.
Well, I mean...
Oh, those are the people that are after us right there.
Yeah, but what does this painting mean on top?
We're free.
Maybe the parents were like, we'll help you.
We'll chase them away.
What did the...
Okay, so this is us helping each other.
Yeah, during the fire that we caused.
And then...
How do we get back down?
I don't know.
Here?
Oh, here.
And this is where, you know, we were trapped in the fire.
We started the fire.
Okay.
And then down here is when I got kidnapped.
Yeah, that shit was crazy.
Yeah, I got kidnapped and you just watched.
I saw you.
I saw you fucking watch.
And then we go down.
And this is when I was like, let's run away from home.
Like right here.
That's where I was like, let's run away from home.
And then you're like, okay.
Because you have like no free will.
You're easily pre-pressured.
And then we're like, yeah, we're free.
We're free.
And then...
And that's when, you know, we started that whole fire.
Like got kidnapped and stuff.
Oh, maybe they wanted to kidnap us so they could like ransom us.
Like hold us hostage.
So like...
And ransom us off to our parents.
Yeah, that's why the eagle crows.
So in the end, we're not bad people for attempting to murder them.
Because they were...
It was self-defense.
No, no, no.
Why are we going back up?
Then why?
I don't know.
We just finished the game.
What do you mean?
Go down.
Why?
Because we were on the second floor.
We need to go to the first floor.
Oh, shit.
You're right.
Okay.
I thought we were on the first floor.
Where's the first painting?
Oh, it's over here.
The first painting.
I can't even see the first painting.
Not gonna lie.
Yeah, I'm not gonna...
We didn't collect enough sparkles.
Wait, what was that fucking puzzle?
Like...
Oh, yeah.
Unravel to...
No, you watch it.
I'm too lazy to...
Okay, link me the video and I'll post it in chat.
Unravel to log puzzle.
It has to be log puzzle, right?
Does it even have that puzzle solution?
Unravel to...
Was it before or after I peed?
It was before.
No, it was after.
Okay, it was after.
We'll never know.
Ashes and ashes.
We'll never...
Okay, unravel to...
I found it.
No...
Okay, can you link it?
Yeah, let me get the timestamp for you.
All right, guys.
This is how the puzzle was supposed to be solved.
Which we didn't solve.
Copy video at timestamp.
And then send to Doki.
All right, this was how you actually solve the puzzle, guys.
All right, let me watch this, too.
All right, let's see how it was done.
Okay.
All right, so we had to tie that while we got the stump.
No, they untied it.
No, they tied it.
They just untied it.
I'm watching them.
If they untied it, it would have a string connected to them.
No, they literally tied it.
No.
And then one pushes it.
Yeah, they tied it.
I think you're a bit ahead of me.
They both tied it.
Is this person playing by themselves?
Yeah, they are.
They don't have friends.
And then...
Yeah, we have a timestamp.
And then, they tied it.
And then, what did they do?
And they swing?
The red tied it, and then the blue tied the other one.
No, they both tied it.
And then...
Isn't this what we did?
Except it took us two years for it?
No, we did something different.
Oh.
No, we did something...
I think you got us a walkthrough where they don't even know how to play the game.
Because they're figuring it out as...
They're literally...
They're figuring it out, like, right, like, on the spot.
Oh, man.
I just need for one with no talking in it.
They're literally, like...
They're so confused.
They're, like, figuring...
No, I didn't...
Wait, they didn't...
It's just tied down...
They restarted the game because...
Hey, I think they did exactly what we did.
Like, we should get that.
No, they did not.
They didn't do what we did.
They tied it.
We didn't tie it like that.
They did not.
We did not.
This...
This is so different.
This is not how you did it.
I'll be honest.
I don't remember.
It's been so long.
This is not even...
It's not even a tutorial.
He was so confused.
Here, let me look up Unravel to Speed Run.
Unravel to any percent solo speed run.
Alright, alright.
GG's.
We did it, guys.
We...
We beat Unravel 2.
This guy beat the entire game within one hour.
Okay, but they're not...
And 50 minutes.
I'm...
Never mind, it took him two hours.
Look, I don't think we're speed runners.
I don't think we're speed runners.
His fastest time was one hour 56 minutes.
You know what, Gumi?
I'm glad we fixed our marriage again.
Yeah, I think at some point that puzzle put a sense of clarity in my mind.
Yeah, like that puzzle literally opened your third eye, right?
Apparently, we brute-forced it.
I...
Yeah, we're gonna have to watch that back.
We're gonna have to watch it.
But we did it, guys.
We did it, everybody.
GG's.
What a...
What a journey.
Also, I can't do the thing tomorrow, because...
My schedule is literally out in public.
I literally have a...
Okay, no.
The thing is, I asked you last week and you were like, I'll get back to you later tonight.
And then I was like, okay, and you never did.
Yeah, but that's...
It was your job to remind me.
It was your job to remind me, you know?
To be like, oh yeah, remember that thing?
You don't want...
It was your job to remind me, you know?
To be like, oh yeah, remember that thing that you wanted to do?
Like, you know?
Anyway, I'm glad we beat a game in our game together, Gumi.
I didn't eat lunch yet, by the way.
I...
All right, so the next one we're gonna play is We Were Here.
All right.
All right, let's...
Whoa, okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait a minute.
Wait, what's We Were Here?
It's a different one.
We...
Oh no, I played this game before.
You have?
Yeah, I played it before.
It was...
In my opinion, if we were struggling on these puzzles, we would struggle in any game from the series.
All right, let's play the cowboy one then.
What the fuck is the cowboy one?
You keep saying cowboy one.
I don't know what you're talking about.
The cowboy one.
What the fuck is cowboy?
Um...
The princess of it takes two.
What?
They made another game, didn't they?
I don't know.
I don't know what the cowboy one is.
A Way Out.
That's not cowboy.
Are they cowboys?
No.
That's not...
It's...
They're...
They're American.
Yeah?
One...
True, true.
One like...
It's like something about prison.
Something...
Cowboys can go to prison?
It's not called prison.
It's like...
Something else.
It's... I forgot what it's called.
It's uh...
Uh...
It's like prison break.
Yeah, but for cowboys, you don't...
It's not called prison.
It's called something else.
It's...
Just...
What is it?
Not dungeon.
It's like a jail.
It's like a jail, but...
It's not...
Yeah, they're in the sheriff's jail.
Yeah, they're in the sheriff's...
I guess so.
I guess.
What is cowboys?
It's not cowboys!
It's not...
It's not a Western!
It's literally prison break.
Anyway, all right.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go grab some food, Gumi.
And you go have fun at Mario Kart.
What time is your Mario...
I don't even know if Kenji's awake, bro.
What time is your Mario Kart collab?
It's supposed to be in 10 minutes.
And I don't even think Kenji's awake.
Wait, who's in it?
It's just Kenji and me.
Oh, oh.
It's just like...
And I'm just confused.
I was like, I thought it's Mario Kart.
What do you mean it's just you two?
No, he...
I like invite him to games.
He's like, I only want to play Mario Kart.
Why?
What's wrong?
Wait, why?
Why Mario Kart of all...
Because he loves Mario Kart.
Oh my god, that freaking freak.
What?
That's like...
That's fucking masochist behavior.
And Mario Kart's like the only game you like.
Let this man enjoy his Mario...
There's so many games!
And it's Mario Kart?
Dude, he just likes Mario Kart, bro.
Yeah.
Still a freak.
All right, all right, Gumi.
I'll message you.
We'll see each other probably next month.
Chi-chis, Gumi.
Chi-chis.
We'll have another marriage cat therapy session next month.
Maybe co-op games aren't it for us.
Maybe...
Maybe we shouldn't do co-op ever again.
Your decision.
No, hey, do you know what?
I think we can be cowboys.
We'll figure it out.
All right.
Oh my god.
I'm hungry, guys.
I'm so hungry right now.
I didn't have time to eat lunch because I went straight into...
I had to go straight into the...
I woke up and I was like...
Okay, gotta walk, dad.
And then do the...
And then get ready for the collab.
And then figure out fucking...
Fucking figure out RoboPlay.
But I hope you guys had fun watching today.
I'm tired.
I'm really tired now.
So I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go grab some food.
I hope you guys had a great time watching.
I still...
I hope like...
I hope the stream went okay because I literally don't have a stream preview.
Like I said, when we're figuring out RoboPlay...
My OBS like fucking destroyed itself.
So I literally had no stream preview.
So I didn't know what was going on.
Or like if you guys can even see the game properly or anything.
I hope you guys had a great time.
And I hope I didn't give you guys any trauma or PTSD.
Or if it felt too real.
Anyway, guys.
As always, everybody, say hi.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Mmm.
Bye.